moment on craignait qu effectivement il
ya des provocations à paris parce que ça
ne peut que servir le gouvernement qui
essaie provocation mais nous nous sommes
essentiellement des usagers à la
coordination nationale des comités de
défense avec effectivement des soignants
des élus d'antan dans nos pays d'enhaut
collectif c'est comme ça que nous que
nous concevons que devrait être le
fonctionnement de la santé en réunissant
pour décider à la fois les usagers les
nuls et et les personnels et comme je le
disais c'est le secteur s'annonce mal
bien évidemment puisque nous on n'a pas
été entendu au ségur on a envoyé une
longue lettre avec nos propositions à
nicole notât parce qu'on veut qu
effectivement à les revendications des
soignants soit il soit entendu il faut
des moyens pour l'hôpital si on a pas
moyen effectivement on n'aura pas de
proximité nous souhaitons on n'aura pas
des soins de qualité donc il faut des
moyens mais pour l'instant manifestement
les syndicats ne sorte n'ont même pas
hier nous avions une réunion avec
l'intersyndicale hier les organisations
syndicales n'avaient toujours pas
rencontré de politique dans les réunions
de ségur c'est à dire pendant
l'impression que le le le ministère
attend pour voir voilà il attend pour
voir les résultats des actions
d'aujourd'hui
je pense qu'effectivement le plat de ce
qui peut se passer à paris il y à une
manifestation énorme en france parce que
la population a compris qu'il ne
s'agissait pas seulement d'applaudir les
soignants mais que si nous voulions
avoir un hôpital public de qualité
il fallait être à côté d'eux pour fait
jamais bon moyen pour le putain on vous
allez rester avec nous on va rejoint
notre reporter a évoqué une grosse
pression donc sur l'exécutif le
gouvernement cette manifestation qui
dégénère cet après-midi ce ségur de la
santé aussi
chi chi et que dénonce beaucoup le
personnel soignant et puis aussi cette
commission parlementaire d'enquêté qui
doit débuter à 17h avec l'audition du
directeur général de la santé jérôme on
va rejoindre tout de suite pour faire un
point sur la situation l'évolution de de
ces tensions et de la manifestation avec
vous nadège abderrazak dites nous
quelles sont vos informations comment ça
évolue maintenant
écoutez samantha l'attention elle est
toujours aussi palpable en a à faire
désormais un face à face assez marquées
entre certains manifestants habillés de
noir et cagoulés et les forces de
l'ordre donc des forces de l'ordre qui
répondent par gaz lacrymogènes un par
des tirs de gaz lacrymogènes en réponse
aux nombreux tirs de projectiles et
qu'il reçoit des forces de l'ordre
qu'ils ont qui ont reculé de quelques
mètres
on sent que là la tension est de plus en
plus palpable les la manifestation est
pour le moment bloqué les
les manifestants se trouvent
actuellement sur la place des invalides
s'il est impossible pour eux d'avancer à
davantage en tout cas pas cas pas avant
que la situation ne se calment donc on a
aussi de nombreux pompiers qui est bien
viennent d'intervenir pour à éteindre
les nombreux feux de poubelles qui ont
été qui ont été allumés a ici à quelques
à quelques mètres donc voilà une tension
qui est de plus en plus palpable on voit
qu'il ya beaucoup d'agitation aussi à
derrière nous puisque donc on va là il
est impossible très difficile de
respirer ici quoi qu'il en soit on va
rejoindre à un brancardier 1 2 de
l'hôpital d'ivry s'appelle rémy rémy
déjà avant de nous dire pourquoi est-ce
que vous avez tenu à être présent
aujourd'hui
que vous inspire le sait cette
dégradation de cette manifestation qui
avait très bien commencé en début
d'après midi
je regrette sincèrement cette situation
est d'autant plus fait de progrès depuis
ce que fait partie du collectif inter
hospitalier que je représente et
et ça me fait mal au coeur de voir ça au
rouge on redoute et malheureusement on a
l'expérience des anciennes
manifestations qu'on peut voir pour me
dire
ça m'attriste profondément parce que
depuis le début tout se passer
correctement
c'était une manifestation bon enfant on
sait se faire entendre et en arriver à
attaquer les forces de l'ordre ce n'est
pas sûr que non ça nous serve à quelque
chose
nous les forces de l'ordre on les voit
quand on passe à côté en laurent les
salue on a du respect pour eux voilà est
allé leur foncer dedans ou leur balancer
des trucs directement c'est inacceptable
inacceptable et en aucun cas nous on
veut que la manifestation des soignants
qui se veut symbolique vient de causer
des dégâts ni aux forces de l'ordre ni à
la république ni aux biens publics parce
que je suis en train de voir ça crame de
pathos expliquez-moi rémy pourquoi
est-ce que du coup vous avez tenu à être
présent aujourd'hui vous vous dites que
c'est de plus en plus difficile pour
vous de faire à exercer votre de métier
pourquoi parce que on n'a pas assez de
personnel humain voilà les patients et
ils sont plus au coeur ils sont plus au
coeur de la préoccupation directement et
nous on veut plus que le patient
devienne une calculette
voilà le fric on s'en fout voilà c'est à
eux de le gérer directement il nous ce
qu'on veut c'est des moyens humains pour
pouvoir s'occuper des patients
correctement une augmentation c'est une
augmentation de salaire pardon pour
pouvoir nous vivre de notre métier
correctement et des moyens
supplémentaires
donc chaque service voilà parce qu'un
service de réa beaucoup plus de moyens a
besoin de plus de moyens qu'un service
de médecine et peu et le service de
médecine a beaucoup plus de moyens qu à
notre service
alors aujourd'hui nous ce qu'on réclame
c'est une augmentation de salaires une
augmentation de moyens humains et une
augmentation de matériel parce que est
ce que l'état français allait les moyens
justement de répondre à ses
revendications et d'augmenter tout le
monde
la santé n'a pas de prix pour reprendre
une phrase et président de la république
on attend de voir du coup parce que
visiblement ça adultes ça quand et pour
l'économie quand et pour l'aviation et
c'est là on peut débloquer les fonds et
on n'a pas besoin à ségur n'a pas besoin
d'attendre cette semaine
pour ce qui nous concerne nous à chaque
fois on n'a pas du bla bla on veut juste
du concret consentent pour marche depuis
tout à l'heure symboliquement parce
qu'on sait très bien qu'on va être
écouté aujourd'hui c'est la première
c'est symbolique
voilà et une nouvelle fois je me permets
de le redire s'est désolé mais je je me
sens presque au nom du collectif et je
m'excuse de céder bart de ces
débordements
je ne peux pas les tolérer je ne peux
pas les accepter et les vivres parce que
je me suis fait gazer pour mais j'en
veux pas non plus aux forces de l'ordre
ils font leur travail et essaie de
maintenir quelque chose voilà nous on
les veut avec nous on n'est pas venu là
pour casser du flic
concrètement merci rémi merci de votre
témoignage
vous l'avez entendu un samir les
personnels hospitaliers qui réclament
plus de moyens rémy qui est bien on
appelle au président de la république
pourrait bien soutenir l'hôpital public
parce que la santé n'a pas de prix dit
il et il reprend les propos du président
de la république
emmanuel macron qui a appelé merci
beaucoup à ne pas manifester
avant-hier lundi dimanche à ne parraine
pas à manifester parce qu'il estime que
ces manifestations sont bien des foyers
potentiels de contamination à quoi qu'il
en soit la tension est toujours palpable
sur cette place des invalides on voit au
loin de nouvelles poubelles incendiées
et des forces de l'ordre qui est bien
désormais encadrent l'intégralité de
cette place des invalides donc très
compliqué d'en sortir
voilà une manifestation qui qui dégénère
et qui ne sert pas la cause des
soignants et bien pour reprendre les
propos de rémy brancardier donc à
l'hôpital d'evry merci nadège votre 1
était donc un qui disais à l'instant pas
question de on n'est pas là pour casser
du flic on va rejoindre l'île afin
amouzou qui suit avec vous ce portage
lit la fin
vous avez dit nous vous qu'est ce que
vous voyez de votre côté et vous avez
entendu aussi se manifestant dire on
n'est pas là aussi pour casser du flic
effectivement mais alors qu'ici tout à
l'heure on disait que la tension était
palpable
elle est réelle maintenant ce n'est plus
juste une impression
l'assignation a totalement mais alors
totalement dégénéré ya à peine encore
une heure tout se passait bien dans la
bonne humeur dans les champs avec un
soleil qui a répondu présent aujourd'hui
qui a répondu à l'appel et puis en fait
d'un coup des individus vêtus de noir
portant des cagoules ont commencé à
lancer des projectiles en direction des
forces de l'ordre qui ont commencé à
riposter et vous le voyez peut-être à
mes yeux l'air est irrespirable
c'est très difficile on a les yeux qui
piquent et effectivement il ya beaucoup
de manifestants ici qui regrette que la
situation ait dégénéré aussi rapidement
et d'ailleurs je suis avec jérôme
rodriguez l'une des figures des gilet
jaune
merci de répondre à nos questions vous
étiez là au début de la manifestation
tout se passait plutôt bien dans
l'absolu oui dans un pacifisme total on
arrivait jusqu'à arriver sur la place
bibard après on a l'habitude en tant que
gilet jaune de recevoir du gaz donc
quelque part ça me ça m'étonne même plus
et toujours dans la même stratégie
que aujourd'hui même certains officiers
de la police remettent en doute du de la
technique du nas âge et de pouvoir
distribuer de la grenade à volonté sur
cette technique l'a donc bienvenue dans
le monde des gilets jaunes
on l'a vu samedi dernier avec la
jeunesse et ceux qui militaient contre
les violences policières on le voit
aujourd'hui contre les soignants qui
reçoivent du gaz alors que certains
policiers à aller devant les hôpitaux
les applaudir bientôt je le dis ils vont
mettre les médailles dans les bd puis
vont les envoyer directement sur les
soignants on a vu que c'était des
individus vêtus de noir qui ont provoqué
quand même les forces de l'ordre au
début
et finalement les ports de nantes sont
en train de lancer des gaz sur à peu
près tout le monde
on a même vu des soignants voilà tombé à
terre c'est quand même on voit que la
situation a totalement dégénéré enfin
tout le monde et des soirées c'est un
bien grand mot parce que quand on
regarde la partie elle est quand même
assez pacifiste il ya quelques petits
pôles
oui ça reste assez tendue le truc c'est
que à eux de faire la différence entre
un soignant keller blouses blanches en
train de de manifester pacifiquement et
ceux qui aujourd'hui mettant en danger
la manifestation mais le problème c'est
qu'il faut foncer dans le tas de ceux
qui sont pas concernés au final donc
voilà on en revient toujours au même
ils ne font pas leur boulot ils sont
plus là pour maintenir le désordre que
de maintenir l'ordre c'est sûr pour
revenir à la raison principale de votre
présence aujourd'hui c'était important
pour vous d'apporter votre soutien au
personnel soignant et de finalement de
passer au delà de des applaudissements à
20h réel moi personnellement je fais
partie des gens capables dit on à ces
marchés pendant un an et demi pour
mettre en avant ce qui n'allait pas
aujourd'hui le virus a été le meilleur
ami des gilets jaunes parce que il n'a
fait que renforcer le sentiment qu'on
nous où on met en place depuis un an et
demi donc ça moi j'ai pas applaudi
maintenant ils sont où tout ceux qui ont
applaudi à la fenêtre
elle est là la tristesse alors
aujourd'hui moi je suis là avec les
soignants pourquoi parce que quand j'ai
perdu mon oeil il était là ces gens là
c'est la policiers qui m'enlève un oeil
et c'est les soignants qui me faire mon
deuil
donc je vais aller soutenir et je vois
surtout les remercier d'avoir répondu à
nos questions
vous entendez samantha des manifestants
qui restent déterminés malgré section
tournure qu'il regrette tous ici écrit
encore une fois je le précise est le
fait d'une d'une minorité d'un petit
groupe de jeunes hommes qui sont
effectivement qui ont commencé à
provoquer des forces de l'ordre et qui
sont ancrées et une situation un peu de
chaos comme vous pouvez le voir autour
de moi merci
beaucoup les la femme ouzou on va vous
retrouver tout à l'heure on va rejoindre
à nouveau michèle leflon présidente de
la coordination nationale des comités de
défense des hôpitaux et maternités de
proximité
vous êtes toujours avec nous on a
entendu l'une des figures du mouvement
des gilet jaune
jérôme rodriguez la présence de cegid et
jaune aux côtés des manifestants qu'en
pensez vous je pense que c'est normal
c'est normal et c'est bien les filets
jaunes sont une des composantes de la
population
ce sont des gens qui se sent avaient
toute leur diversité
mais beaucoup mobilisé pour trait la
fermeture des services publics dans un
certain nombre de territoires la
désertification le contrôle et les
fermetures de services dans les hôpitaux
ils ont participé à un certain nombre
d'actions à côté des comités de défense
des hôpitaux
donc c'est normal qu'il soit là
aujourd'hui parce que je le répète ce
n'est pas uniquement les soignants qui
sont ceux c'est bien l'ensemble de la
population qui doit obtenir du
gouvernement une reconnaissance des
besoins des hôpitaux publics
c'est une question de santé publique
c'est une question de salubrité
je disais tout à l'heure tu es une
grosse pression sur l'exécutif le
gouvernement
d'abord on voit cette manifestation qui
dégénère cet après midi
ont il ya une commission d'enquêté
parlementaire qui doit se dérouler à 10
à partir de 17h avec jérôme salomon qui
va être entendu le directeur général de
la santé pour faire toute la lumière sur
la gestion de l'épidémie par les
autorités et puis ce ségur de la santé
également comme beaucoup de vos
confrères aux critiques mais évidemment
le ségur de la santé pour le sol le
gouvernement n'a rien mis sur la table
il écoute et il n'a pas fait de
proposition
or pour qu'il puisse y avoir des
négociations
il faut des propositions de part et
d'autre et pour l'instant le
gouvernement le président de la
république se contente de dire on va
mettre les soignants à l'honneur le 14
juillet mais c'est pas de ça dont on a
besoin c'est qu'effectivement les
revendications soient satisfaites
c'est qu'effectivement il ya des moyens
pour la santé pour nos hôpitaux tous y
compris les hôpitaux de proximité qu'il
y ait des moyens
nous on défend aussi la création de
centres de santé
là où on manque de mes deux médecins
généralistes pour assurer pour aller
faire un véritable service de soins
publics de proximité
parce que ce n'est pas vrai il ya des
endroits où c'est très très compliqué de
se faire soigner et tristement c'est à
la fois dans certains quartiers de paris
où il n'y a pas de médecin sans
dépassement d'honoraires etc
dans un certain nombre de campagnes et
de et john suburbaines donc c'est normal
que la population se mobilise et c'est
normal que les jets les jaunes d'oeufs
puis ce participer
à cette action aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
chez moi j'en dis j'ai vu quelques gilet
jaune qu'on avait vu l'année dernière
mais c'était avec les soignants
aujourd'hui avec la population parce que
y avait chez moi bien d'un côté de la
peu à côté des soignants une partie
importante de la population qui s'était
mobilisée pour soutenir les soignants
mais pour aussi dire que leur
revendication c'était dans l'intérêt de
l'ensemble de la population
cette convergence entre les gilet jaune
et les personnels soignants peut-être
encore cette réaction parce qu'on sort à
peine d'une crise sanitaire qui n'est
pas encore terminée d'ampleur on a vécu
cinquante cinq jours en france en tout
cas en confinement et on en est encore
là aujourd'hui
comment vous l'expliquez il ya eu des
promesses aussi on a eu le sentiment que
le il ya une prise de conscience de
l'exécutif sur cette question des moyens
alloués aux systèmes de santé et on en
est là aujourd'hui comment vous
l'expliquez et bien je pense que pour
l'instant le gouvernement fait plus
d'efforts pour soutenir le patronat
permettez moi de dire ça que les
soignants et et bien évidemment il faut
des mesures de relance de l'économie
mais lâche antennes de la population ça
fait partie des mesures d'aidé des
mesures pourquoi changer la situation et
pour que l'épidémie serve à quelque
chose il nous faut effectivement plus de
moyens pour la santé plus de moyens pour
les services publics globalement le
président de la république a reconnu
leur valeur bain dans son maquis
médecins en application
et c'est un certain nombre de choix
politiques effectivement que d'encre et
ton qui ne fasse pas lui laisser le
temps quand même à ce gouvernement
qu'en pensez vous oui mais en
l'occurrence si vous voulez sur cette
question de la santé
il a été averti avant l'épidémie
le 14 novembre via une grande
manifestation à à paris il ya une
manifestation à charleville moi j'étais
à paris
lamy qui a représenté notre comité des
chances dans la délégation qui a eu ce
jour-là à l'adresse des ardennes a dit
au directeur de la rs l'hôpital si
jamais il ya une épidémie l'hôpital
n'est pas capable de faire face
donc c'est pas nouveau le gouvernement a
eu peut-être pris conscience pendant
l'épidémie
mais il ne peut pas dire qu'ils
n'avaient pas été averties avant les
mesures qui ont été annoncées après le
14 novembre ne répondait rien du tout et
lille a annoncé il a annoncé des
millions et des millions mais je te
l'essentiel c'était pour reprendre la
dette du tiers des hôpitaux et y compris
ça c'est extrêmement retord parce que
c'est c'étaient les hôpitaux qui se
conduisent bien et qui annonce à nouveau
des fermetures de lits et de
suppressions postes de personnel on va
leur voix leur faire cadeau de leur
dette
donc y compris il y avait rien dans ces
annonces la et n'avait pas compris mais
on ne peut pas dire qu'ils découvrent le
problème en tout cas vous êtes vous
resté avec nous michèle leflon merci 1
pour cette réaction des règles rappelle
que président de la coordination
nationale des comités de défense des
hôpitaux et maternités de proximité on
suit en direct cette grande journée de
manifestation de paris à montpellier en
passant par metz dunkerque bobigny
plus de 220 rassemblements prévus
aujourd'hui dans le cadre d'une journée
d'action nationale organisée à l'appel
d'une dizaine de syndicats et de
collectifs de soignants et une journée à
paris tendu où on va rejoindre tout de
suite katia technique a eu des heurts
qui ont éclaté dans la capitale entre
des manifestants et les forces de
l'ordre on a pu voir des gars des forces
de l'ordre intervenir à coups de gaz
lacrymogènes pour disperser les
manifestants des véhicules dégradés
katia technique quelle est la situation
de votre côté les tensions et elles
perdurent on voit nous les forces de
l'ordre continuent et leurs
interventions pour tenter de disperser
les manifestants
ceux qui sèment le col oui en effet mais
en effet il ya des charges de très
nombreuses charges alors les les forces
de l'ordre qu leur reviennent beaucoup
de gaz lacrymogènes bon disons que c'est
un reste sur un certain périmètre et
sinon les les soignants sur les bords
parce que bon c'est quand même plutôt
des des éléments radicaux bien sûr un
qui sont aux prises avec les forces de
l'ordre les autres soignants sont sur
les côtés et
et attendent ils restent là parce que
c'est leur journée donc ils ne veulent
pas évidemment se disperser et sans
arrêt donc des charges se produisent des
gros nuages de gaz lacrymogènes mais
évidemment il faut garder en tête la
mobilisation principal la mobilisation
du jour une nouvelle saison nationale
très attendue pour porter des
revendications qui existe depuis déjà un
an et demi je suis avec le docteur
enrico toby chirurgien pédiatre alors
docteur aujourd'hui c'était une journée
de plus pour exprimer à vos
revendications
c'est quand même une journée
particulière parce que c'est la première
grosse et premier gros rassemblement
après l'épisode du coc vide
et ben on a une fois de plus on voit
on voit
ce qui est en train de se passer c'est à
dire on voit la considération qu'on peut
avoir nous les soignants sans ce général
c'est à dire que nos revendications
aujourd'hui pas plus qu'hier ne sont
écoutés par contre évidemment à la
moindre provocation hélas il ya quelques
black block qui provoque
bon ben voilà tout le monde prend du gaz
lacrymogène donc c'est c'est la
continuité mais c'est vrai que ça fait
quand même
assez mal après ce qui s'est passé en
france avec l'épidémie covit de voir que
des le premier rassemblement bon ben
voilà c'est le même traitement
inquiets qui est donnée donc un jour on
cogne sur les pompiers aujourd'hui c'est
des soignants c'est du grand n'importe
quoi
voilà ce qui se passe je suis pas
surpris parce que ça fait un moment que
ça dure
par contre l'espoir c'est que les gens
se rendent compte petit à petit de la
façon dont est gouvernée
voilà je pense que ça devient criant bon
après on peut toujours garder les yeux
fermés
mais à partir au mans les ouvre ça
devient assez évident quand même nous ne
sommes pas écoutés
nos revendications ne sont pas prises en
compte cette histoire de ségur mais
penchez-vous un petit peu sur la façon
dont ça a été monté à toute vitesse
c'est de la rigolade
1 c'est de la rigolade voilà donc vous
trouvez que les revendications ne sont
pas prises en compte dans ce secteur là
pour l'est les premières retombées que
vous avez absolument absolument pas
c'est dire que c'est vraiment une fois
de plus un peu comme le grand débat un
pouvoir sur quoi le grand débat abouti
c'est c'est un pur scandale renseignez
vous pour savoir où sont les doléances
écrites les dizaines de milliers de
doléances écrites par les français et
renseignez vous pour savoir où elles
sont aujourd'hui dans quel plat car
elles sont donc c'est tout simplement
pour meubler et pour essayer de
canaliser un petit peu cette colère bien
légitime qui a absolument partout voilà
bon aux gens de se rendre compte dans
quel
pays on vit sous quel type de régime en
vie c'est c'est ça devient complètement
inacceptable voilà bon moi ça fait un
moment que je ne l'acceptent plus
on va être de plus en plus nombreux
c'est juste évident et si les réponses
qu'on a à chaque fois c'est ce type de
réponse c'est à dire que on a une police
qui est comme ça agressive
bon ça va rien arranger c'est pas comme
ça qu'on va régler le problème il ya des
problèmes de fond à partir de quand on
les aborde réellement et je peux vous
dire que ce ségur vous verrez bien
rendez vous dans trois mois vous verrez
ça va déboucher sur rien la différence
avec avancé qu on le sait maintenant on
sait voilà c'est pas comme ça que on
arrivera à changé dans le fond les
problèmes de fond qui existe avec cette
épidémie de vide
tout le monde a pu se rendre compte que
l'hôpital public a été en partie
démantelé on est en sous-effectif on est
incapable de faire face la santé en
france soit disant la meilleure du monde
le monde entier a vu ce que c'était a vu
qu' on est dans une situation
extrêmement dégradée
voilà bon donc ça c'est le problème de
fond est ce qu'on laborde ou est-ce
qu'on n'aborde pas merci beaucoup
monsieur dr kotô been nous avoir fait
part de vos impressions évidemment delà
de l'amertume 1 lors de cette
manifestation qui a tourné finalement à
l'affrontement
en espérant que les revendications
aujourd'hui à des soignants sont tout de
même audible entendues notamment dans ce
contexte de ségur et pour la situation
ici qui a l'air de se calmer un peu nous
vous tiendrons au courant au fur et à
mesure beaucoup avouent qu'elles
technique on va retrouver tout de suite
on y retrouve riche et le flon vous êtes
toujours avec mon président de la
coordination nationale des comités de
défense des hôpitaux et maternités de
proximité vous donc vous suivez avec
nous cette journée de mobilisation très
tendu apparemment ça commence à se
calmer on
restait quand même prudent sur le
positionnement des syndicats leur
soutien aujourd'hui on l'a entendu des
syndicats exprimé tout à l'heure des
craintes vis-à-vis de la suite de cette
manifestation
le couac possible pour cette journée est
ce que vous vous craignez au moment où
on se parle justement que cette journée
se soit un couac également mais je pense
que je vois ce qui se passe partout en
france
alors évidemment c'est dramatique d un
des incidents à paris et il faudra
chercher quelles sont les
responsabilités parce que les soignants
la population voulait d'une
manifestation calme et épicé dommage
mais je pense que ça ne remet pas en
cause la profondeur de mouvement et le
profond soutien de la population au
soigneur est alors hôpital public et un
hôpital public ils veulent de proximité
et pas comme les précédentes lois les
dernières lois de long d'où l'on fait
des usines à gaz où on rassemble les
hôpitaux dans des combats hospital et
territoires où les fusions tout ça où il
n'y a plus aucune notion de proximité
il n'ya plus le service au public et est
donc qui a il faut qu'on revienne en
arrière parce que effectivement comme ça
a été dit dans une des interviews
précédente
nos systèmes de santé des le meilleur du
monde il ne l'est plus le système de
santé qui n'est plus le meilleur du
monde selon voit peut-être un
commentaire de votre part sur les
chiffres plusieurs milliers de
manifestants a annoncé à paris à lyon
ce sont des chiffres les premiers
chiffres qui nous parviennent au moins
4000 manifestants à bordeaux 3500 à
marseille selon la police deux mille six
cents à 5000 à montpellier
3000 1500 à 3000 à caen à rennes 1300
également à 3000 manifestants on a vu
que pendant le confinement tous les
soirs les français étaient à leur balcon
pour encourager les personnels soignants
les félicite et vous auriez vous pensez
que les manifestants ne sont pas assez
nombreux il aurait fallu peut-être que
les françaises se joignent aussi de
manière plus massive à ces
manifestations dans toute la france
ben on peut toujours on peut toujours
servir moi ce que j'ai vu chez moi c'est
en gros un qu'un tiers de deux soigneurs
et et deux tiers dans la population avec
de notre comité défense avait lancé un
appel pour que d'autres organisations
politiques associatives syndicales nous
rejoigne il y avait des enseignants par
exemple avec la fsu mais il ya aussi des
associations comme attac comme la ligue
des droits de l'homme qui ont fait des
communiqués nationaux d'ailleurs de
soutien et la population est en train de
se mobiliser alors effectivement le voir
ce que ça donne ce soir mais le
gouvernement à la dette un peu sourd
donc sans doute qu'il va falloir
recommencer il ya déjà deux dames qui
sont en débat qui sont le 30 juin qui
sont le 14 juillet parce que vous savez
que le président de la république de
mettre à l'honneur les soignants au
cours de la fête nationale mais c'est
pas ça dont ils ont besoin eux ils ont
envie de faire leur boulot correctement
et donc d'avoir des moyens pour les
hôpitaux
ils ont à vivre de rendre service à la
population c'est pour ça qu'ils font ce
métier là c'est pas donc voilà il ya il
va y avoir sans doute d'autres
manifestations
mais vous savez les gens y travaillent
quand même donc il y a
il ya justement des gens qui ont fait
l'effort de participer aux
manifestations pour soutenir les
soignants aujourd'hui c'est bien et nous
y compris ont fait une autre
un autre rassemblement ailleurs dans le
département ce soir à 18 heures
justement pour que la population qui
travaillent puissent s'associer à cette
à ça donc ce qu'il faut voir c'est qu'il
ya partout dans les plus petites villes
il ya eu il ya des rassemblements
parce que la population avec les
soignants ils ont tous envie de dire
qu'il nous faut qu'il nous faut des
moyens parce que c'est pas que la santé
n'a pas de prix mais c'est le b à ba du
bien vivre en france et puis et puis
c'est vrai que on voit tellement
d'argent qui part dans d'autres
directions qu'on pense que c'est quand
même important
cette prise en charge de la question de
la santé
vous êtes donc à charleville mézières à
vous dites qu'un rassemblement prévu du
coût de chez vous à 18 heures et 18
heures à sedan
voilà à sedan alors juste juste une
réaction encore je devrais votre votre
avis est ce que vous pensez qu'au sein
même des personnels soignants on voit
qu'à une colère aussi cette journée
le montrent il ya c'est vrai qu'il ya
des profils radicaux des black blocks on
en a parlé mais il ya aussi une vraie
colère de la part des personnels
soignants
est ce que vous pensez qu'il peut y
avoir une sorte de radicalisation aussi
chez chez les soignants aujourd'hui n'en
peuvent plus ils n'en peuvent plus de
cette situation d'être en attente de
moyens pour le système de santé de santé
les soigner en son pote
les juniors sont pas des violents donc
voilà je vous demande je pense je pense
que c'est ce que constatent des
soignants et j'en ai vu j'en ai vu plein
dans la magnifique ville dès qu'ils ne
sont pas des habitués des cortèges de
manifestations ils sont effectivement
extrêmement dépité parce que non
seulement le président de la république
a fait des discours dont seulement ils
ont travaillé dur pendant la période du
confinement est bon département a été
relativement épargné par le colis mais
ça quand même pour des bandes d
organiser leur travail et maintenant la
direction de l'hôpital et je pense que 7
6 ici comme partout en france veut
s'appuyer sur un certain nombre de
changements d'organisation de changement
d'horaire liés à l'épidémie et eux les
soignants avaient accepté parce que ça
permettait de faire face à un certain
nombre de choses
la direction veut s'appuyer là dessus
pour aggraver leurs conditions de
travail encore et encore et ça c'est pas
c'est pas acceptable
donc effectivement les soignants sont
extrêmement extrêmement mobilisés ils
sont et ils sont prêts à descendre
beaucoup plus dans la rue peel de le
faisait il ya un an et votre message
pour conclure à l'adresse justement du
gouvernement qui dira
on sait olivier ferrand le mini de la
santé dit on avance on travaille en
avance votre message bern ots message
c'est que il suffit pas de travailler et
de et d'avancer il faut savoir dans
quelle direction on avance et il nous au
niveau de la coordination nationale nous
avons vraiment l'impression qu'il faut
changer de direction
il faut changer direction il faut
arrêter de vouloir faire des économies
il faut arrêter de vouloir orienter de
plus en plus les patients vers les
cliniques privées pour en gros qu'il ya
des pros fait qu'il soit fait sur la
santé il faut arrêter des regroupements
il faut qu'on puisse avoir des soins
dans la proximité
dès qu'il ne s'agit pas de spécialité
qui nécessitent des plateaux techniques
lourds
merci beaucoup avoue michèle leflon
d'avoir réagi en direct sur arte france
alors que se déroule cette grande
journée d'action nationale en français à
paris je rappelle que vous êtes la
présidente de la coordination nationale
des comités de défense des hôpitaux et
maternités de proximité merci à vous bon
courage
on va retrouver maintenant nadège
abderrazak qui suit donc l'évolution de
cette manifestation n'a d'âge ce que la
situation se calme
manon samantha on peut pas vraiment
parler d'un cas denis vous le voyez
peut-être derrière moi on a des forces
de l'ordre qui procèdent à de nombreux
tirs de gaz lacrymogènes pour tenter au
maximum de repousser les manifestants
pourquoi repousser les manifestants et
mia puisqu'ils ont réussi justement
certains éléments en tout cas radi quoi
repousser les forces de l'ordre qui
avaient réduit de manière un peu plus
importante
cette classe d'aider des invalides de
ses forces de l'ordre ont reculé de
plusieurs mètres ils se sont elles se
sont montrés un peu plus discrète
pendant un quart d'heure vingt minutes
et elle réplique désormais assez
systématiquement avec mr bergues est la
réplique systématiquement à un coup de
gaz lacrymogènes des forces de l'ordre
qui avaient un moment procéder à des
arrestations des interpellations ciblées
mais ça a été une des méthodes
d'interpellation qui a été impossible à
poursuivre c'était impossible pour les
forces de l'ordre de poursuivre
interpellé de manière plus ciblée c'est
certains éléments radicaux parce que la
réponse
la réponse de ces éléments radicaux bien
se montrer intense plus importante que
ce que je peux vous dire est bien c'est
que on a d'un côté certains manifestants
pacifistes qui sont désabusés un de voir
comment voir la suite de cette
manifestation qui avait pourtant bien
commencé et de l'autre un face à face
assez intenses entre les forces de
l'ordre et plusieurs plusieurs
manifestants et donc voilà on peut pas
parler d'accalmie
de retour au calme ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que les forces de l'ordre
sont plus discrètes que tout à l'heure
et qu'elle procède maintenant pour
tenter de repousser les manifestants à
coup de gaz lacrymogène on va peut-être
rejoindre alexandre alexandrie les
techniciens de laboratoire à l'hôpital
beaujon à clichy alexandre dit moi je
vous vois vous m'aviez vous dit vous
êtes un peu désabusé de voir comment se
poursuit cette manifestation qui avait
pourtant bien commencé
aux abords du ministère de la santé
votre réaction
voilà moi ça me rend triste parce qu'en
fait toutes ces personnes ne se rendent
pas compte que ils sont frères il s'agit
aujourd'hui de défendre les valeurs de
l'humanité je pense et ce qui est en
train de se passer là dans ces tristes
moi ça me rend triste
je suis passionné soignants je devais
vous ma vie allait bien que je sois que
technicien de laboratoire
je suis d'abord personnel soignant c'est
à dire je me dévoue pour aider les
personnes qui ont besoin quel que soit
leur situation
quelles que soient leurs uniformes voilà
il ya des personnes qui vont être blessé
aujourd'hui elles vont toutes se
retrouver à l'hôpital
et quand elles seront assises ou
allongées les unes à côté des autres
eh bien elles se rendront compte que
d'abord elles sont humaines et c'est ce
manque d'humanité aujourd'hui je pense
moi qui me rend triste et la lutte qu'il
faut mener aujourd'hui c'est retrouver
les liens entre les uns les unes les
autres
au delà des au delà des uniformes au
delà de ce qu'on défend on a tous et
toutes des positions différentes
mais on respire le même air on s'en est
rendu compte avec cette situation
comment un virus a pu d'une part mettre
en évidence la fragilité de notre
humanité en même temps montré que c'est
à travers des valeurs de solidarité que
on va pouvoir se retrouver et une fois
de plus c'est bien
la haine reprend reprend le dessus en
quelque sorte
moi ce que je souhaiterais c'est que
évidemment ça fait partie de la réalité
mais peut-être de focaliser un peu plus
sur toutes ces personnes qui elles
restent pacifiques voilà et sont là et
comme moi et bien son triste parce que
parce qu'elles sont venus défendre comme
valeur bavois être salis tout simplement
par des personnes qui sont pas
conscientes de ce qu'elles sont en train
de faire alors il faut que faut changer
là et le temps est venu vraiment d'un
grand changement
et personnellement je vois du fond de
mon coeur pour que ça se passe de
manière de la manière la plus paisible
possible alors il ya encore du travail
voilà mais je suis absolument convaincu
que si on regarde tous au même endroit
et que l'on cesse de s'unir dans nos
divisions et que on retrouve la
conscience du fait que ben voilà nous
sommes d'abord des êtres humains quoi
l'hôpital public est malade aujourd'hui
pourquoi est ce que vous avez fait le
déplacement participer à cette grande
manifestation aujourd'hui du 16 juin
parce que l'hôpital aujourd'hui ça
représente le symbole le dernier symbole
peut-être de ce que peut être le lien
entre les humains à savoir la vie ou la
mort puisque personnel soignant est
confronté à ça en permanence on se bat
pour sauver des vies et on se rencontre
en fait que dans nos sociétés bien que
ce soit pour les personnes âgées ou pour
les hôpitaux les valeurs humaines
aujourd'hui disparaissent
parce que voilà une perte de conscience
tout est devenu monnayable comptable
raisonnable donc on cherche simplement à
casser ce qui reste d'humanité de
fraternité et moi je me bats uniquement
pour défendre cette valeur là vous
croyez pas aux ségur de la santé il me
semble que c'est bien mal engagée parce
que c'est dur de la santé va être une
fois de plus une discussion politique
c'est à dire une discussion qui va
d'abord faire appel à des discours et à
des schémas de pensée plutôt que se
retrouver dans le coeur alors que là la
situation mériterait que l'on prenne
conscience de je le redis notre
fragilité ça veut dire que pour ça on
est obligé maintenant de mettre à plat
énormément de choses de retrouver le
lien l'humanité au-delà des difficultés
financières qui sont en fait je pense on
peut les régler voilà la dette de la
france est colossal vous pensez qu'il
est qu'on peut trouver de l'argent pour
l'hopital
il faut trouver alors la dette ça
n'existe pas vous voyez demain vous
allez voir un banquier il va l'ouvrir
une ligne il va mettre cent mille euros
dessus cet argent n'existe pas à la
dette c'est le plus grand mensonge la
plus grande manipulation qui a été mise
en place depuis les années 70 la dette
c'est simple les 20 personnes les plus
puissantes du monde se réunissent autour
d'une table et décide de remettre les
compteurs à zéro et et on repartirait
sur des valeurs qui seraient des valeurs
réaliste et plus basée sur des mensonges
financier calculateur on s'est bien fait
avoir dans cette histoire
personnellement
le réveil a été douloureux quand j'ai
compris ça mais maintenant c'est une
réalité
donc il faut défendre ça alexandre merci
pour ce témoignage rappelle que vous
êtes technicien de laboratoire à
l'hôpital beaujon à clichy merci merci
beaucoup donc au vous avez entendu cette
colère et cette déception de ce
technicien de laboratoire qui estime
qu'aujourd'hui c'était le jour le jour
où il fallait montrer bien justement que
le personnel hospitalier étaient
mobilisés pour demander pacifiquement
plus de moyens pour l'hôpital public
un technicien de laboratoire qui comme
beaucoup d'autres manifestants et ci
s'est montré déçu de la suite des
événements une manifestation qui a donc
dégénéré ici place des invalides avec
des affrontements assez récurrent entre
forces de l'ordre et et certains
certains éléments cagoulés et habillés
de noir notamment
merci beaucoup nadège ad razak on le
voit oui effectivement les forces de
l'ordre continuent d'intervenir pour
disperser les les profils les plus
radicaux en marge de cette manifestation
c'est en tout cas qu'ils ont soumis le
tout mais où des échauffourées dont qui
ont éclaté lors de cette manifestation
du côté des invalides manifestations des
personnels soignants avec des jets de
projectiles
auxquelles les forces de l'ordre ont
répondu on l'a vu tout au long de cet
après midi par des tirs de gaz
lacrymogène
on dès qu'on dénombre 16 interpellations
selon la préfecture de police de paris
donc seize interpellations va écouter
quelques témoignages de manifestants
justement aux invalides pour cette
grande journée d'action nationale qui a
dégénéré à paris on est systématiquement
contre la violence mais le pouvoir a
décidé qu'il jouerait sur la violence
sur la violence sur la violence pour
dire regardez c'est infect gens ces
soignants à qui on dit bravo bravo
et bien aujourd'hui on va l'aider crac
et bientôt comme des dangereux
personnage lé voilà ce fameux peuple
hrvatska avec de la rigueur il ne fait
pourquoi mais il le fait parce qu'il
n'en peut plus il est submergé en
l'autre lui donne une dette ou qu'elle
augmentait de 40 % 1
on a fermé plus de 2300 société
nationale enfin tant qu'à augmenter en
fait le chômage de plus de 10 e de 2009
6,2 de personnes naïves à y aura une
vague au coeur de millions de personnes
qui voient arriver on va arriver où la
vallée jusqu'à où ça m'attriste
profondément
parce que depuis le début tout se passer
correctement c'était une manifestation
bon enfant on sait faire entendre et en
arriver à attaquer les forces de l'ordre
ne suis pas sûr que nous ça nous serve à
quelque chose
nous les forces de l'ordre on les voit
quand on passe à côté alors on les salue
on a du respect pour eux voilà est allé
leur foncer dedans ou leur balancer des
trucs directement c'est inacceptable ça
fait quand même
assez mal après ce qui s'est passé en
france avec l'épidémie covit de voir que
des le premier rassemblement bon ben
voilà c'est le même traitement
inquiets qui est donnée donc un jour on
cogne sur les pompiers aujourd'hui c'est
des soignants c'est du grand n'importe
quoi
l'espoir c'est que les gens se rendent
compte petit à petit de la façon dont
est gouvernée
voilà je pense que ça devient criant bon
après on peut toujours garder les yeux
fermés
mais à partir mans les ouvre ça devient
assez évident quand même nous ne sommes
pas écoutés
nos revendications ne sont pas prises en
compte
voilà pour ces réactions donc deux
manifestants
on retrouve donc on se dirige vers
toujours vers les invalides on voit
toujours ces images en direct et la
situation elle est extrêmement tendue du
côté donc des invalides où se déroule
cette grande manifestation d'aidés
soignants à paris c'est l'épicentre de
cette manifestation dans la capitale
c'est une dans le cadre d'une grande
journée d'action nationale des
manifestations qui se déroulent
également en province et on voit qu'à
paris bien la situation a dégénéré
il y a maintenant plus d'une heure les
forces de l'ordre qui sont entreprises
donc avec une poignée de d'individus
sains qui ont commencé à jeter des
projectiles sur les forces de l'ordre
donc des provocations auxquelles ces
mêmes forces de l'ordre ont répondu par
des tirs de gaz lacrymogène on les voit
ici
ces forces de l'ordre qui interviennent
maintenant c'est un va et vient
incessant entre ces forces de l'ordre et
des manifestants qui certains
manifestants qui tentent de leur
échapper il ya eu seize interpellations
selon la préfecture de police de paris
ces interpellations une journée donc de
mobilisation qui a débuté pourtant dans
le calme c'est une manifestation
évidemment des personnels soignants qui
se voulait pacifique mais qui a très
vite dégénérer on voit du côté donc
des invalides ont varié rejoindre li la
fameuse où tout de suite pour faire le
point on voit que derrière elle c'est
assez étendu autour d'elle en tout cas
les la face que vous m'entendez vous
êtes oui vous m'entendez et la fameuse
on voit que c'est très tendu autour de
vous essayer de nous raconter un brio
les règles ce qui se passe concrètement
oui alors je suis obligée de wall street
et de m'éloigner samantha parce que en
gros c'est vraiment la situation en
train de devenir mais totalement a
totalement dégénéré la brûler les
membres des voltigeurs en fait son
arrivée il ya à peine cinq minutes
hélas si vous voulez ça encore plus
embrasser en fait les petits groupes de
deux hommes dont on vous a parlé tout à
l'heure qui sont vêtus de noir et qui
sont en fait responsable de voile à 2 du
fait que la situation dégénère mais
alors mais totalement entre est ce qu'on
a vu qu'on est arrivé au début de
l'année de la manifestation aux
alentours de 14h30 15h et ce qui se
passe maintenant c'est c'est absolument
incroyable en fait il n'ya pas du tout
de moments d'accalmie constamment en
fait à peu près toutes les deux trois
minutes on voit des affrontements entre
donc certains un groupe de manifestants
et les forces de l'ordre qui en fait
réplique maintenant systématiquement ne
reste plus du trou stoïque et c'est vrai
que on a rencontré beaucoup de gens ici
qui nous ont dit qu'ils étaient très
déçus de la situation dégénère à ce
point là
d'ailleurs je suis avec keller leduc kg
les jaunes depuis la première heure
merci de répondre à nos questions désolé
je suis un peu essoufflée parce qu on
court beaucoup depuis tout à l'heure
vous êtes g légion depuis le début vous
vouliez rendre enfin montrer votre
soutien aux soignants aujourd'hui est
finalement voilà ce que ça donne
maintenant cette manifestation ça vous
inspire quoi bassam aspire je suis
vraiment désolé parce qu'il n'ya pas
longtemps la police à venez applaudir
devant les hôpitaux et aujourd'hui on
avait un moment un très beau symbole on
a vu beaucoup de personnes soignants qui
ont avancé qui disait macron t'es foutu
l'hôpital et dans la rue
ces personnes là avance et on applaudit
sans les mains en l'air et ils ont été
chargés aussi aujourd'hui la fête pour
les soignants l'hommage pour les
soignants a été gâchée par les assauts
policiers alors oui il ya eu des
altercations
mais c'est encore une fois dommage que
les policiers
gâche les symboles qui a représenté
l'hôpital qui a sauvé nos vies
aujourd'hui et avoue finalement les
gilets jaunes jeunes on vous suit depuis
le début du mouvement
et je me rappelle que en mai 2010 vous
ai dit vous aviez déjà participé à une
manifestation en soutien aux hôpitaux
donc c'est quand même une thématique qui
vous tient à coeur depuis le départ mais
oui c'est une thématique qui nous tient
à coeur parce que depuis le départ on a
parlé un petit peu de la casse de nos
hôpitaux la casse de notre santé et la
casse à les casser allez allez faites
par le gouvernement
on lutte pour toutes ces cas sont lutte
pour toutes ces injustices et il ya un
moment on en a marre forcément on dit ah
le peuple est en colère c'est normal que
papier en colère on casse les hôpitaux
on casse nos services publics on enlève
nos zones aux lits dans les hôpitaux et
un moment c'est plus possible
alors finalement qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que nouveau qu'est ce que vous allez
faire après cette manifestation
d'aujourd'hui qui finalement ne se passe
pas comme c'était prévu mais qui est
quand même la première manifestation on
va dire autorisée depuis la fin du
confinement est ce que qu'est ce qui va
se passer pour le mouvement des gels et
jaune maintenant alors vous avez pris
moi personnellement ce que j'ai prévu
c'est qu'on va continuer à essayer de
travailler pour la convergence il ya un
moment on a envie on a tous le même
objectif
finalement c'est d'enlever ce
gouvernement qui fait n'importe quoi sur
tous les thèmes tous les thèmes soit la
santé que soit la justice que ce soit la
santé tous sur tous les thèmes il ya un
moment on va continuer et un moment si
on a tous le même objectif qui est
d'enlever ce gouvernement c'est qu'on va
tous aller dans la rue en même temps
pour type même si on a des idées
différentes mais en tout cas l'objectif
il est le même donc on va travailler
ensemble pour essayer de faire ensemble
soit tous ensemble dans la rue
une dernière question gaylord leduc
alors les gilet jaune ça mouvement qui a
commencé le 17 novembre 2018 très
exactement depuis on a vu beaucoup de
mouvements de protestation que ce soit
contre la réforme des retraites
par exemple est-ce que vous avez
l'impression d'avoir été quelque part
précurseur de la colère générale de la
colère sociale dans ce pays précurseur
je vais pas avoir la modestie de dire
que le mouvement était le précurseur le
mouvement a permis d'éveiller des
consciences mais les précurseurs il y en
a qui se bat depuis plus de vingt ans il
n'était pas forcément gilet jaune mais
ils le sont aujourd'hui
il ya plein de gens qui se battaient
pour sa déjà avant qui pointait déjà les
injustices notamment par exemple hier
dans les quartiers aussi donc il ya un
moment nous on n'est pas précurseur
on a juste permis d'éveiller plus de
conscience
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
alors samantha vous l'entendez la
détermination reste la même un même si
effectivement cette mobilisation ne se
passe pas du tout comme prévu alors je
vous dis on connaît très peu de monde
accalmie ici aulnoye régulièrement
toutes les cinq minutes d un démon des
échauffourées on va dire des
affrontements entre les forces de
l'ordre et certains groupes d'hommes
vêtus de noir et cagoulés
et c'est vrai que l'air est absolument
irrespirable de ce côté de la plaque
vraiment cette manifestation qui avait
commencé je rappelle encore une fois
dans le calme est en train de totalement
des génériques totalement merci beaucoup
les l'afa un mot nous et on a
effectivement entendu votre micro un
gilet jaune ils sont quand même assez
quelques-uns à s'être rejoint cette
mobilisation dans la capitale on va le
rappeler il ya plusieurs milliers de
manifestants à paris ce sont dés les
premiers chiffres à lyon également et
puis beaucoup de manifestations de
également en province 4000 manifestants
par exemple à bordeaux 3500 à marseille
le bilan de ces tensions et de signer
j'ai chaud forêt entre certains
manifestants et les forces de l'ordre et
bien 16 interpellations et puis ce tweet
16 interpellations selon la préfecture
de police de paris puis ce tweet
toujours de la préfecture de police
des groupes violents temps de faire
dégénérer la manifestation pacifique des
soignants
la préfecture appelle au calme et à la
responsabilité des individus virulents
voilà pour ce tweet on va rejoindre
stéphane augé qui est chef du service
réanimation pédiatrique à l'hôpital
robert debré à paris
bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous votre réaction à ces tensions
ces échauffourées ces heurts entre
certains manifestants certains qui ont
un profil de radis radical et les forces
de l'ordre
bonjour madame je n'ai pas de réaction
particulière
j'ai dû quitter la manifestation des
soignants pour aller à un jury de thèse
vers 15h et je découvre les images en
même temps que vous je suis vraiment
très triste de ce qui se passe ça n'a
pas grand chose à voir avec les
soignantes je remarque juste que quand
je suis arrivé dans le cortège des
collègues qui étaient arrivés avant moi
disait que les forces de l'ordre avaient
provoqué un petit peu à la sortie du
métro
j'étais très étonné de saint-josse
espérer que ce n'est pas ça mais
apparemment les images que jouer en même
temps que vous ne sont pas de cet ordre
là des gens sont venus pour en découdre
je peux vous garantir que ce ne sont pas
les soignants du coup c'est vraiment
dommageable et maniable pour l'usinage
que ça va donner de nos manifestations
qui étaient pacifiques et vous venez de
le signaler qu'ils étaient extrêmement
nombreux surtout territoire apparemment
vous nous disiez à l'instant que vous
avez eu des échos des informations selon
lesquelles les forces de l'ordre
auraient provoqué des manifestants à la
sortie du nom à l'arrivée à la
manifestation les forces de l'ordre
semblaient déjà en lui je n'ai rien dit
et je n'étais pas la prestation déjà
plusieurs plusieurs heures je ne peux
pas vous dire plus que ça effectivement
sans doute que les policiers
s'attendaient à des débordements
certains de mes collègues ont signifié
que l arrivée à la manifestation il
avait vu que les policiers étaient
tendues voilà c'est tout ce que j'ai dit
une énième d'autres je ne suis plus la
manifestation des policiers des
policiers tendions on a bien compris sur
cette journée de mobilisation qui se
déroule en plein c ur de la santé oms et
c'était eux une journée d'action à paris
en tout cas et sur tout le territoire
importante pour les personnels soignants
pour vous tous
oh qu'est ce qui va se passer maintenant
l'avenir de cette manifestation à paris
parce que ça se déroule aussi en
province donc on va pas non plus noircir
le tableau mais vous pensez que la vos
revendications elles vont être entendus
que le message il va passer tout de même
on va écouter je ne sais pas un homme ça
n'a pas grand chose à voir tout ce qui a
été fait avant le travail qui a été fait
entre autres par le collectif danger je
suis un des membres est extrêmement
important nous avons participé aux
seniors avec la rue en état policier est
retenue c'est pas uniquement des
débordements qui ont lieu en ce moment
mais l'ensemble des personnels et des
citoyens des usagers qui sont venus nous
soutenir dans les villes de france de
vendre tous les hôpitaux
quel que soit qu'ils soient privés ou ni
sur tout le territoire je pense que
c'est quand même ça le message et
j'espère j'ose espérer que le
gouvernement va se servir de ces
affrontements
le champ de manifestation uniquement à
paris pour remettre en cause de la
mobilisation surtout la motivation des
personnels pour avoir centres de service
et un confort et salo clairement
d'autres revendications nous voulons une
nouvelle rupture pour soigner nos
citoyens c'est la seule motivation de
des gens qui étaient très nombreux
devant le ministère de la santé
le jour alors vous parlez du ségur de la
santé on sait que pour beaucoup de
personnel soignant
ça n'avance pas assez vite et on voit
que dans la rue c'est difficile de faire
entendre sa voix parce que c'est
compliqué de manifester sans qu'il y ait
aujourd'hui des débordements d or
comment on fait
maintenir ses revendications et faire
avancer les choses
le dialogue avec ce gouvernement côté
même la manifestation était un des actes
unitaire tous les syndicats ont appelé à
venir les collectifs ont été aussi et
jusqu'à ses débordements
encore une fois j'ai moins de temps vous
la balle de la manifestation ce cas
c'est très bien je pense que on a eu
confirmation de la volonté des usagers
défense et de défendre l'obtient les
défendre le système de santé pour le
remettre au niveau de ce dont nous avons
besoin d'autres actions sont en cours
comme vous le savez sans doute mais on a
sans doute oublié mais le conseil
économique social et environnemental
travaillent d'arrache-pied pour proposer
aussi à parler de concertation nationale
des points forts pour réformer le
système dont l'hôpital public une grande
conférence est organisée le 2 juillet
encore d'autres propositions ont été
faites tout au long du ségur pour
l'instant n'ont entendu de j'espère que
ça va changer aussi
et donc on a quand même beaucoup de
levier pour montrer notre bonne volonté
et la bonne volonté s'est avancé
construire un hôpital de demain
basée essentiellement sur une
revalorisation des salaires l'arrêt de
la fermeture des lits une gestion de
bonne qualité adaptés aux besoins du
territoire avec l'ensemble des soignants
et non soignants de ciel unique
participe aux décisions adaptées à la
population ce n'est pas les heures on
voit en ce moment qui devrait remettre
en cause ses motivations
merci à vous stéphane 2g chef de la
réanimation pédiatrique à l'hôpital
robert debré vous restez avec nous si
vous pouvez on va rejoindre tout de
suite notre reporter pour faire le point
sur la situation katia technique qu'à
tiens quelle est la situation de votre
côté
écoutez toujours une situation d'extrême
tension et de batailles rangées au
centre de l'esplanade charge surcharge
beaucoup de de gaz lacrymogène en a vu d
une charge et très violente de la brave
avec des interpellations consécutive la
tout à l'heure on entendait le chiffre
de 2 16 interpellations nous on a vu
deux ici derrière moi en fait alors ici
c'est un peu plus calme on s'est mis en
retrait parce que ça devenait vraiment
irrespirable on pleurait beaucoup en
fait y'a même des scènes de
fraternisation presque entre les forces
de l'ordre et les soignants est ici donc
un peu d'accalmie mais ils ont mis en
marche
le camion doté de canons à eau donc
j'imagine que c'est l'étape suivante
pour disperser les manifestants en
nombre mais pour nous parler de cette
manifestation qui a été gâchée
évidemment par les nombreuses
échauffourées je suis avec ap sabah qui
est aide soignante
alors elle ça va vous qu'est ce que vous
avez pensé cette manifestation donc la
manifestation au début a bien commencé
tout s'est bien passé aventures de mots
le cortège a démarré on a commencé nos
champs de l'eau slogan tout d'un coup
ils ont commencé à casser
donc à nous gazer moi je trouve
inadmissible le fait qu'on vienne pour
voilà en fait réclamer nos droits et
nous du compte on retrouve en fait
encercler comme des voleurs assure gaz
et avoir les yeux qui pleurent le nez
qui pique avec des bombes lacrymogènes
c'est tout à fait et en soignant que
c'est très dangereux et moi je trouve ça
inadmissible et le fait que voilà nous
on met quand même notre santé en jeu
pour venir en aide à la population et
qu'on se retrouve en fait encercler
comme des voleurs se trouve ça
inadmissible il faudrait peut-être que
le gouvernement se réveille parce que
c'est bien beau d derrière un bureau est
de donner des conseils mais quand on est
sur le terrain même ce n'est pas la même
chose
actuellement les hôpitaux son manque de
matériel en manque d'effectif ça je le
dis haut et fort on se retrouve
maintenant avec des dents des services
avec 23 passion pour un an ferme et une
étonnante trouve ça inadmissible
donc nous on est épuisé on n'est pas
écoutés on se sent délaissé il faudrait
que l'état
soit quelque chose sinon ça risque de
mal finir
parce que vu que nous prend comme des
délinquants bas s'ils continuent comme
ça les gens vont se prendre contre les
délinquants voilà le problème aussi
c'est qu'aujourd'hui à des éléments
radicaux qui sont allé provoquer la
police le souci c'est que c'est ça a été
aussi les gazelles ont concerné aussi
des soignants c'est ça le problème
voilà moi comme j'ai dit je trouve
injuste le fait que nous mais nous tous
dans le même sac
parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des
casseurs c'est les casseurs mais nous
les soignons une venus pacifiquement et
je trouve inadmissible qu'il fasse un
mélange de tout le monde et là il n'ya
pas dix soignants ni casseurs on est
tout mélanger on nous gave nous tous et
puis voilà voilà le vécu d'absa bas une
aide soignante 5e 6 témoigner des
difficultés des soignants général
évidemment dans cette période de crise
sanitaire un des besoins de moyens je
rappelle les revendications à des
revalorisations salariales
une création de lits l'arrêt de la
fermeture des lits et des rustres
restructurations l'arrêt de la
tarification à l'acte mais évidemment
toutes ces revendications sont un peu
moins audible avec les échauffourées en
ce moment vous entendez certainement
derrière moi des bruits de grenade ebodé
et puis il ya encore des charges à
nombreux des gaz lacrymogènes qui vole
avec une inverse et des canons à eau en
préparation donc voilà pour l'ambiance
en ce moment sur l'épreuve des invalides
katia on voit d'ailleurs que
certains manifestants cours continuent
de provoquer lancent des projectiles
vers les forces de l'ordre pour les
provoquer il ya ce tweet katia technique
de la préfecture de police de paris
le voici des groupes violents qui
tentent de faire dégénérer la
manifestation pacifique des soignants la
préfecture de police qui appelle au
calme et à la responsabilité des
individus virulents et u16
interpellation katia technique est ce
que vous vous avez pu vous avez des
informations sur ces manifestants qui
sèment le trouble en marge de ce
rassemblement à paris que vous avez pu
observer si vous si vous voulez les
manifestants étant oui ils sont cagoulés
ils sont masqués donc si vous voulez les
informations elles sont assez limités
tout le monde court dans tous les sens
et sin scènes de chaos comme le
rappelait l'aide soignante si vous
voulez tout le monde se fait gazer sans
distinction que ce soit les éléments
radicaux le black block 1 qui qui qui
est présent aujourd'hui très présent et
très virulent donc si vous voulez
et malheureusement tout le monde est
logé à la même enseigne
tous les professionnels les syndicats
les élus tout le monde a reçu des gaz
lacrymogènes et éventuellement des
charges quand on ne court pas assez vite
ce qui est clair c'est bien entendu il
ya des éléments radicaux pour une
manifestation de soignants ils sont
extrêmement nombreux il y en a eu
d'autres et avec moins de débordements
mais là comme tout le monde est bloquée
si vous voulez sur l'esplanade des
invalides
les gens sont comme dans une souricière
donkey à charge contre chapsal et les
gens courent ils se remettent en
position et puis les forces de l'ordre
recherchent donc je pense que maintenant
l'étape c'est les canons à eau sur les
éléments moment on sait très bien que
sont des éléments radicaux et et du
black block qui évidemment ne ne se
cache pas de de faire un ce type
d'action aujourd'hui mais on vous
imaginer qu'avec les masques aujourd'hui
évidemment beaucoup de manifestants
quels qu'ils soient porte des masses
donc plus les cagoles évidemment on on a
très très peu d'informations sûres sur
les éléments qui qui provoque la police
est donc vous parler des canons à eau
ce sera probablement au moment de la
dispersion donc il faut s'attendre vont
être à des tensions
il tente l'art d'ici là la dispersion
pas votre avis il m'a écouté
oui en fait si vous voulez on a vu sur
les tweets que il parlait déjà de
dispersion alors qu'actuellement il ya
énormément de personnes sur la place qui
n'ont absolument pas envie d'être
dispersés runes qui sont toujours sur
les la manifestation mais tout à l'heure
le canon à eau n'avait pas été mis en
marche en fait là on enfin le camion je
dirais là le moteur a été enclenchée ce
qui signifie que quelque chose se
prépare donc pour pour la suite un c'est
évident mais là je vois encore les gens
courir dans tous les sens c'est encore
extrêmement actif au point de vue des
détentions et des options avec les
forces de l'ordre énormément de deux
jets de projectiles à nos journalistes a
été blessée d'ailleurs assez gravement
sur la jambe en fait il a quand même
pris certainement une pierre bon là ça
courant on voit énorme s'il vous plaît
depuis tout à l'heure il ya des jets de
gaz lacrymogène
d'une part vraiment d'une épaisseur
assez considérable et c'est en
permanence depuis plusieurs heures
merci beaucoup beaucoup il écrit les
jauges oui bah oui je vous dise c'est
vraiment une scène un peu de chaos il ya
toujours du mobilier qui brûle en fait
le mobilier urbain attendez je vais je
me déplace un peu pour qu'on puisse voir
un peu si vous voulez voilà le mobilier
urbain brûle les gens courent dans tous
les sens et
et les les forces de l'ordre ges jette
donc des gaz lacrymogènes donc comme
vous voyez il reste encore beaucoup de
l'individu de soignants de tous types de
manifestants sur la place qui ne veulent
pas partir évidemment parce que les
soignants depuis le départ ne veulent
pas quitter la place puisque c'est
l'heure oui oui absolument tout à
l'heure les syndicats ont fait une
annonce en disant nous on ne va pas
abandonner le terrain nous sommes nous
sommes là pour revendiquer et on va pas
laisser ces affrontements gâcher anneaux
notre journée de protestation de
revendications donc oui il ya encore des
soignants alors même si les si vous
voulez les camions des syndicats ont
quitté pour la plupart la place en
envoie un peu qu'ils sont en train de
justement de ma de quitter les lieux
mais sinon il reste encore des soignants
on voit les blouses blanches clairement
élan restants et les soignants katia
technique vous les avez entendus je
reprends au milieu d'après-midi ils sont
dépités ces syndicats
alors moi j'ai pas forcément intervenus
des syndicalistes mais chez les
soignants oui ils ont ils sont déçus si
vous voulez ils sont déçus que ça allait
tourner comme ça alors certains blâment
aujourd'hui les individus qui ont
provoqué la police d'autres noms ont
préféré constater le fait que quoi quel
que soit le mode d'action les quelles
que soient les revendications finalement
ils ne sont pas entendus
donc pour eux c'est une journée de plus
d une journée de plus durant laquelle
ils sont dans la rue et selon ça tourne
encore court en fait donc il ya une
sorte de de lassitude dans la profession
qui est désespéré de voir que quels que
soient les moyens à employer donc les
les grèves des urgences le fait d'aller
dans la rue eh bien il n'arrive pas du
tout à leur fin ils n'arrivent pas à
faire entendre leurs revendications qui
sont évidemment davantage de moyens
comme disait tout à l'heure et l'arrêt
de la fermeture des lits et autres
revendications à qui son attrait
précisant et qui sont toujours pas
entendus merci beaucoup katia technique
16 interpellations c'est le bilan que
nous a donné la préfecture de police de
paris a aussi des blessés on a vu tout à
l'heure un blessé on
il reviendra tout à l'heure on va
écouter je vous propose d'écouter cette
réaction d'anne hidalgo la maire de
paris s'est exprimé beaucoup plus tôt
sur la nécessité de recentrer l'économie
vers le milieu médical
il faut réorienter notre économie vers
la santé vers le soin on a bien vu qu'on
a besoin de tous ces métiers qui
évidemment ne peuvent pas être mis
exactement sur le terrain de métiers
dans lesquels il y a
là une compétition une compétitivité on
est dans les métiers du soin dans les
métiers de l'humain et il faut vraiment
que on réoriente y compris la dépense
publique vers ces métiers essentiels on
a bien vu qu'on ne peut pas se passer
d'un système qui soit solidaire
performant qui prennent en compte les
plus fragiles je pense à nos aînés je
pense aussi aux personnes sans domicile
fixe aux personnes isolées
on va rejoindre maintenant gérard
brémond il est président de france à sos
santé
bonjour à vous merci de réagir en direct
sur arte france
une journée d'action nationale avec des
échauffourées des débordements des
tensions des violences à paris du côté
des invalides comment vous réagissez
malheureusement s'attendre
c'est violent cela et que certainement
aujourd'hui ce mode de manifestations et
de revendications ne sont plus adaptées
à l'enjeu des problèmes qui sont devant
nous dans le système de santé
effectivement pour nous représentants de
l'ensemble des usagers de la santé
la revalorisation des salaires de
l'ensemble de ceux qui les soignent
n'est même pas une question c'est une
évidence même par contre ce qui nous
paraît important aujourd'hui c'est
comment nous redonnons du sens à à à
l'ensemble des professions médicales
dans une refonte totale de notre système
de santé qui doit se fonder sur
l'humanisme sûr
les attentes et les besoins de
succession on a du sens aux métiers que
sont les métiers de soignants et
l'ensemble des métiers qui sont des
métiers grâce au ltte donc on voit bien
aujourd'hui que ce genre de
manifestation là ne correspond plus du
tout à à des attentes et des besoins de
notre système de santé malheureusement
on ne peut que déplorer ces groupuscules
qui viennent se greffer à des
revendications tout à fait légitime de
l'ensemble des soignants mais qui
effectivement forme dégénérée ces
matches c'est sûr là écrit le social
quand vous dites que c'est plus possible
aujourd'hui de faire entendre sa voix de
cette manière cela vous surprend pas du
tout parce que depuis longtemps combien
c'est difficile de faire un temps
effectivement des revendications
catégorielles ou sociale tu écrives
comme les mener je crois que nous sommes
arrivés à un goût d'un système là la
crise e.coli 10,9 l'a parfaitement bien
démontrer a été un révélateur est un
accélérateur des mesures nécessaires en
profondeur dans notre société
comment redonner de la démocratie me
sens dans notre système de santé
reconnaître la valeur de ce qu'ils sont
des acteurs de ce système de santé et et
donner beaucoup plus de responsabilités
aux acteurs que ce sont eux qui sont sur
le terrain qui seront plus proches dé
soigner
y compris d'ailleurs les soigner et les
sommets au plus proche l'eau pour nous
ce qui est important c'est de
véritablement mettre en oeuvre une
démocratie de l'ensemble des soignants
et des acteurs de la santé sur des
territoires données pour pouvoir
répondre aux attentes et aux besoins des
patients dont les huit ans aux métiers
aux métiers de la santé
c'est plus important mais et était
certainement revaloriser l'ensemble des
dénés salariés qui sont domaine de la
santé
le ségur de la saleté et qui débouchera
effectivement comme d'habitude je
quelques mesurettes qui ne rouvriront
pas effectivement les énormes de juin il
faut que je profite et peut-être de
cette réflexion la renommée une
véritable réforme de fond de
l'organisation de notre système de santé
et donner la responsabilité à ceux qui
soignent pas simplement nos
administratif et pour faire vieux
système le sommes des descendants
jacobins du le paris jusqu'au jusque sur
les territoires mais bientôt mais bien
plus les verts sz
c'est à dire les territoires ceux qui
sont acteurs au plus proche des besoins
et des attentes de ceux qui souffrent
les patients et faire remonter
effectivement ses attentes de ses
besoins
donc il ya une nécessité à ce que tout
le monde fasse mais recule pas snober
notables et réfléchissent renversé
effectivement la gouvernance de ce
système nous sommes des ces
manifestations la montre l'exaspération
d'un corps médical qui a été extrêmement
courageux et est magnifique le temps de
cette crise du cros vide mais qui
demande à être entendu pour ce qu'il est
et pour les services opérant dans la
société
est ce que vous craignez vous qu'il y
ait des amalgames
quand on voit ce type de deux heures
lors de cette manifestation des
personnels soignants on sait qu'on est
dans un contexte international un peu
particulier en france c'est le cas aussi
avec les dénonciations de violences
policières présumées de racisme
présumées au sein des forces de l'ordre
vous vous craignez des amalgames
la récupération pour bien entendu de
récupération et de morgane par les
groupes politiques ou autres mais
effectivement cette situation est
éminemment politique on voit bien
aujourd'hui que un autre notre
démocratie de la représentation est mise
en difficulté et que nous faut réfléchir
posément mois ces événements on peut
s'interroger comment on peut réfléchir
une façon posée responsables à trouver
une démocratie plus participative où
chacun pourra se sentir beaucoup plus
participatif à la création d'un nouveau
système
c'est une démarche nouvelle qui nous
faut mener effectivement ça passe par
des tensions qui sont inquiétantes de
jeu je pense pour bon nombre de
personnes qui sont favorables à ce que
la démocratie continue insu pays et
comment on fait aujourd'hui
si on ne manifeste pas si on ne va pas
le pavé dans la rue pour revendiquer des
mesures du changement comment est ce
qu'on fait pour faire entendre sa voix
aujourd'hui vous parler de démocratie
participative ce n'est pas la première
fois qu'on entend d'ailleurs ces termes
ce n'est et des études peuvent être
menées le vert parce qu'effectivement la
la la la manifestation publique peut
montrer une certaine revendications mais
à côté de la revendication du blick il
faut être une capacité de pouvoir
solliciter des réunions des rencontres
voir travailler et on a bien vu par le
passé après des manifestations
les responsables qu'ils soient syndicaux
ou institutionnels se mettre autour
d'une table et réfléchir pour trouver
des solutions et je pense que
effectivement leur ne va pas semblant si
on reste dans la tension et dans la
violence
on n'arrivera pas à construire quelque
chose de consensuel et de qui lui
permettra l'expression de l'ensemble des
parties c'est ça qui nous inquiète
donc il faut savoir mener les deux
manifestez revendiqué avec les moyens
qui sont les nôtres en restant le plus
d'emplois possible même tenue mais aussi
être en capacité de pouvoir se mettre
autour d'une table et de pouvoir faire
progresser dans tout système de santé
dans l'intérêt de tous particulièrement
l'intérêt des soignants et l'intérêt de
soirée merci beaucoup à vous gérard
raymond président de france aso sentez
vous restez avec nous d'ailleurs si
c'est possible de votre côté on va voir
prendre tout à l'heure en attendant on
va retrouver nadège abderrazak qui suit
toujours
cette manifestation qui a dégénéré à
paris nadège alors comment ça se passe
de votre côté quels sont vos
informations à écouter samantha on a
affaire un épisode d'ac2 légère accalmie
pour l'instant on a des forces de
l'ordre qui sont à l'écart qui est on
tenté de procéder à des interpellations
ciblées pour justement écarter les
éléments radicaux faire en sorte de les
différencier des manifestants des
soignants ça a été compliqué puisque en
face à des forces de l'ordre on a des
centaines d'éléments radicaux des
centaines d'individus cagoulés habillés
de noir des individus et bien qu'ils se
mêlent au reste du cortège donc c'est
très compliqué pour les forces de
l'ordre d'intervenir de maintenir le
calme aujourd'hui alors de ce
rassemblement cette manifestation des
soignants des médecins des infirmiers en
colère qui réclament plus de moyens pour
l'hôpital public ils réclament des
augmentations de salaires 300 euros de
plus par mois pour s'aligner sur la
moyenne européenne ils réclament aussi
des créations de postes l'arrêt des
fermetures d'établissements de services
donné il faut savoir qu'au cours des six
dernières années 17500 l'iran 10
rue dans les hôpitaux publics donc voilà
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
beaucoup de matériel urbain a été
dégradé des poubelles ont été incendiées
on a des pompiers qui sont aussi
mobilisé beaucoup de street medic et qui
interviennent cet après midi pour venir
en aide aux blessés on est blessé et qui
se comptent par dizaines
ici sur cette place des invalides on a
des manifestants les journalistes
également qu'ils ont été blessés dont
l'un des nôtres un chai sur rt france
donc voilà les gaz lacrymogènes répond
systématiquement aux jets de projectiles
on a des manifestants est derrière qui
scandent assez régulièrement à des
slogans hostiles aux forces de l'ordre
mais également aux gouvernements des
slogans qui ont visé à christophe
castaner le ministre de l'intérieur mais
également emmanuel macron le président
de la république à qui on réclame la
démission
voilà une manifestation qui avait bien
commencé dans la bonne humeur au départ
du ministère de l'intérieur ministère de
la santé pardon et qui sait a dégradé
qui a dégénéré ici sur cette place des
invalides une situation encore très
critique ici il est 17h et la plume et
il ya toujours autant de monde en sueur
sur cette place des invalides ans va
rejoindre deux infirmiers de l'hôpital
de dreux qui ont fait le déplacement
aujourd'hui pour faire entendre leur
colère
il estime avoir été abandonné par par le
gouvernement alexandre vous êtes
infirmier vous pourquoi
déjà vous êtes ici aujourd'hui ici tout
d'abord pour faire entendre notre cause
pour pouvoir faire comprendre entre
guillemets aux dirigeants qu on l a déjà
pour soigner les gens
ok on reçoit un salaire pour ça on est
pas assez d'effectifs depuis des années
des années les budgets sont serrés les
budgets sont bloqués les gens sont
malheureusement parfois mal soignée avec
toute la bonne volonté qu'on puisse
qu'on puisse y mettre
on est là aujourd'hui pour essayer de
faire entendre notre voix ouais vous
pensez que ça fait des années et des
années que les derniers les les
gouvernements successifs les les
précédents gouvernements ont taillé dans
les effectifs ont diminué les budget
vous pensez que cette crise est liée au
kobus 19 elle a révélé les failles du
système de santé français tout à fait
elle a réveillé alors révélé non
seulement les failles mais la capacité
des dirigeants à on va dire à répondre à
une demande ponctuelle à voilà des
musées milieu d'hôpitaux on s'organise
ouais malgré des milliards dépensés en
effet ça fait jaser ça
qu'est ce que vous réclamez vous êtes
infirmier ça se passe comment au
quotidien votre votre profession au
quotidien comment ça se passe on reçoit
des personnes bas on l'a on la choisit
aussi
certes c'est dur on est là pour ça le
point central nous dans notre boulot
c'est le patient convient qui est
accueilli à l'hôpital et qu'on soigne du
mieux qu'on peut quoi vous inspire et
bien la suite de cette manifestation
aujourd'hui complètement dégénéré sur
cette thèse des envies d'ailleurs n'a
pas pu finir notre notre parcours on a
été on a été encerclé ici des familles
ont été ont été gazés aussi
est-ce que ce qu'on veut pas nous mettre
des bâtons dans les roues est ce qu'on
veut est-ce qu'on veut pas on va dire à
étouffer un petit peu là
ouais attendait alexis on va rejoindre
alexis vous vous me dites alex et alexis
oui je disais que ya un peu de gilet
jaune isation en fait on va faire penser
que la manifestation est violente pour
nous décrédibiliser le discours du
discours il est réel on a besoin de
moyens on a besoin de collègues en plus
on a besoin d'un peu plus aussi pour
vivre parce que parce qu'un fermier
s'est laissé c'est noël c'est laid c'est
l'anniversaire de son fils c'est l'essai
s'est laissé une partie de sa vie ou au
service des autres et derrière et
derrière voilà on demande pas
grand-chose ne demande pas grand chose
un peu de reconnaissance un petit peu
plus de d'argent par rapport à notre
spécificité on a un travail qui est très
très technique moi je suis infirmier en
psychiatrie
j'ai été mobilisé pour le govic j'ai dû
revoir mes compétences les remettre en
les remettre en action donc on nous
demande une gamme de savoir et on ne
paye pas en conséquence on ne paye pas
en conséquence de ce qu'on nous prend
cette prime kovy delà de 1000 1500 euros
elle suffit pas assez bien mais c'est
pas assez
franchement ça va être ça va être dur ce
que je vais dire mais j'ai l'impression
d'avoir été prise pour une escorte quoi
on s'est servi de moi on me jette
maintenant allez prends tes 1500 et
vatan la couleur de l'eau de l'hôpital
elle est bien plus profonde que ça comme
vous en parliez tout à l'heure ça fait
dix ans qu'il ya des coupes budgétaires
ça fait dix ans qu'on nous met des
administratifs en plus et pour obtenir
le moindre médicament ou le moindre
matériel de soin c'est compliqué ça
passe par des bons ça passe par des
systèmes informatiques qui font des
cotations
on nous informe tout le temps de ce
qu'on dépense comme si nous nous le seul
intérêt qu'on a dans là dedans c'est la
vie humaine intérêts financiers on peut
pas travailler avec ces ségur de la
santé alors vous y croyez pas on a
invité les infirmiers participer
- sera ma réponse on n'y est pas
pourquoi est-ce que vous avez tenu à
venir aujourd'hui emmanuel macron lors
de son allocution dimanche il a dit aux
français de limiter justement d'éviter
les rassemblements
vous avez pas forcément écouté les
consignes du président de la république
pourquoi parce que la colère elle est
trop fort c'est que danger j'ai été mis
trois mots en danger dans un service
qu'ovide par manque de matériel d'accord
ça ça a été cautionnée par l'état tout
le monde pouvait commander des masques
qu'ils ont juste interdit de le faire je
prend pas plus de risques d'être
infectés peur d'être autour de 30
patients qu'aux vide à l'heure actuelle
ce sera ma réponse je suis pas plus
dangereux
vous avez de l'espoir quand même que ça
s'améliore parce qu'on dit on demande
beaucoup d'argent à l'hôpital public est
ce que est ce qu'on en a suffisamment
dans les caisses de l'état de l'argent
je pense que pour certains intérêts oui
il ya de l'argent et puis pas pour
d'autres y en a pas pour la santé pour
le social il ya ça fait longtemps qu'ils
a plus beaucoup dans les caisses quoi
après voilà faut peut-être répartir les
caisses quoi vous faut réfléchir
autrement mais de toute façon cette
crise elle a montré que sans l'hôpital
on serait pas grand chose quoi merci
beaucoup alexis merci à vous également
alexandre infirmiers je le disais à
l'hôpital de dreux
donc on voit là une manifestation qui se
poursuit si la place des invalides avec
de nombreux à épisodes de tensions entre
les forces de l'ordre d'un côté et
plusieurs éléments radicaux de l'autre
qui est bien völler en décours en
découdre avec les forces de l'ordre une
manifestation qui se poursuit
difficilement je vous propose d'écouter
certains manifestants justement
aujourd'hui qui ont tenu à participer
aujourd'hui à cette manifestation
massoud inadmissible le fait qu'on
vienne pour voilà en fait un clamé nos
droits et nous du on se retrouve en fait
encercler comme deux voleurs assure gaz
et avoir les yeux qui pleurent de nez
qui pique avec des bombes lacrymogènes
concil tout à fait et en soignant que
c'est très dangereux
moi je trouve ça inadmissible et le fait
que voilà nous on met quand même notre
santé en juin pour venir en aide à la
population et qu'on se retrouve en fait
encercler comme des voleurs se trouve ça
inadmissible le faudrait peut être que
le gouvernement se réveille parce que
c'est bien beau d derrière un bureau est
de donner des conseils mais quand on est
sur le terrain même ce n'est pas la même
chose actuellement les hôpitaux son
manque de matériel en manque d'effectif
ça je le dis haut et fort on te retrouve
maintenant dans des services avec votre
passion pour en affirmer une étonnante
c'est inadmissible qu'une équipe
physique on n'est pas écoutés on se sent
délaissé il faudrait que l'étape quelque
chose ou sinon de m'abstenir
parce que vu qu on nous prend comme
modèle encore bas s'ils continuent comme
ça les gens vont se prendre combler dès
la con on est systématiquement contre la
violence mais le pouvoir a décidé qu'il
jouerait sur la violence sur la violence
sur la violence pour dire regardez c'est
infect gens ces soignants à qui on
disait bravo bravo bravo
et bien aujourd'hui on va l'aider crac
et bientôt comme dédé dangereux
personnage
ce fameux peuple qui revendiquent avec
de l ardeur il ne fait pourquoi mais il
le fait parce qu'il n'en peut plus il
est submergé
non l'autre lui donner une dette auquel
ça augmentait de 40 % 1
on a fermé plus de 2300 société
nationale en 20 ans tend à augmenter en
fait le chômage de plus de 10 e de 2009
6 de personnes mais il va y avoir une
vague au coeur de millions de personnes
qui voient arriver on va arriver où la
vallée jusqu'à où ça m'attriste
profondément
parce que depuis le début tout se passer
correctement c'était une manifestation
bon enfant on sait faire entendre et en
arriver à attaquer les forces de l'ordre
ne suis pas sûr que nous ça nous serve à
quelque chose
nous les forces de l'ordre on les voit
quand on passe à côté on les salue on a
du respect pour eux
voilà est allé leur foncer dedans ou
leur balancer des trucs directement
c'est inacceptable ça fait quand même
assez mal après ce qui s'est passé en
france avec l'épidémie qui vide de voir
que des le premier rassemblement bon ben
voilà c'est le même traitement
inquiets qui donnait donc un jour on
cogne sur les pompiers aujourd'hui c'est
des soignants c'est du grand n'importe
quoi
l'espoir c'est que les gens se rendent
compte petit à petit de la façon dont
est gouvernée
voilà je pense que ça devient criant bon
après on peut toujours garder les yeux
fermés
mais à partir mans les ouvre ça devient
assez évident quand même ne sommes pas
écoutés
nos revendications ne sont pas prises en
compte
[Musique]
oui donc voilà une manifestation qui se
poursuit avec un passé retraite
actuellement entre les forces de l'ordre
qui en recul à un petit peu et quelques
manifestants qui font face aux forces de
l'ordre on a beaucoup de matériel urbain
abîmé des poubelles incendiées regardé
un seul regard des incendies on a de
nombreux
route qui ont été à dépanner donc on va
une situation est très tendue où je vous
parlais tout à l'heure d'éléments
radicaux et bien cette place des
invalides
elle se évident au fur et à mesure on
sent que voilà on se dirige vers une fin
de manifestation
voilà en tout cas on peut peut-être
commencer à parler de retour au au calme
même si la tension est toujours palpable
elle s'est vidée 1,7 place des invalides
on a beaucoup moins d'éléments radicaux
que tout à l'heure il reste uniquement
quelques quelques manifestants quelques
membres du personnel soignant
actuellement et quelques gilet jaune
aussi qui sont présents aujourd'hui si
neige pour toutes ces informations
manifestation qui se déroule on le
rappelle également en province un dans
la plupart des grandes villes de
l'hexagone donc une grande journée
d'action nationale des personnels
soignants qui se déroule aux provinces
dans le calme même si à paris on a vu
donc ces rassemblements dégénéré et puis
cette image forte à des tensions
aujourd'hui entre les forces de l'ordre
et les manifestants
regardez cette manifestante en blouse
blanche
sur ces images que l'on suppose être une
professionnelle de santé elle est
brutalement été percuté par un charge à
des forces de l'ordre violente et le
stration de cette manifestation des
soignants donc cet après midi on va
retrouver un invité
enrique casalino il est chef des
urgences à l'hôpital bichat alors que
l'on voit donc que cette manifestante un
qui est donc est par terre et les forces
de l'ordre au milieu des forces de
l'ordre bonjour à vous enrique casino
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france comment vous réagissez à ces
manifestations qui ont dégénéré
aujourd'hui à paris du côté des
invalides écoutez je suis outré
manifester est un droit
je trouve que la manifestation les
soignants qui sont venus ont exprimé un
certain nombre de demandes légitimes et
une certaine insatisfaction que je veux
parfaitement partagé avec eux
connaissent leur mouvement leur
mouvement a été volé par une série
d'accidents de personnes qui ne
respectent pas le monde de soignants et
qui me barton ne partageons pas nos
valeurs
ce n'est pas acceptable
le gouvernement allant cliquer avait
l'obligation de garantir la sécurité et
soignants joly tient rigueur comme jeudi
un rigueur aux personnes qui ont profité
de ses occasions pour voler ce qui est
une revendication légitime des soignants
c'est absolument inacceptable ces images
aulas ne dit pas que ce sont des
manifestants ce sont des personnes
violentes qui ont contenu ont fait
dériver la manifestation sont en aucun
cas des personnes qui partagent les
valeurs des soignants vous dites que
vous en tenir rigueur aux autorités qui
devaient normalement assurer la sécurité
des manifestants on voit que ça a été
plutôt compliqué pour ces autorise pour
ses forces de l'ordre de d'exercer
justement lors leur mission vous en vous
à qui on sait que par exemple ministre
de l'intérieur un christophe castaner il
traverse une passe difficile sur fond de
polémique autour des violences
policières présumées
vous pointez du doigt concrètement je ne
vais pas pointer quelqu'un ou une
personne je pense que nous avons un
problème en france il n'y a plus une
manifestation qu'ils le soient pas
prises en otage par un certain nombre
d'individus qui sont une minorité et qui
viennent complètement détruire le
message social
la revendication sociale le droit ne
pourra exprimer une revendication et le
droit de thomas exprime éventuellement
un désaccord
ce n'est pas acceptable ça c'est la
responsabilité de l'état donc d'autres
pays on a fait pour le football et on a
protégé le football mais on n'est pas
capable de protéger en france les
légitimes revendications catégorielles
dans ce cas-là du monde de la santé
le monde de la santé pourrait devrait
pouvoir défiler en respectant les règles
touré devrait pouvoir défiler en faisant
part de ses revendications et ne pas se
trouver entre deux feux entre des
personnes violentes et la police qui
essaye de garder l'ordre
tout ça aurait dû être réglée très en un
mot ce n'est pas acceptable
absolument pas acceptable le monde de la
santé n'avait pas besoin de ça nous
sommes déjà en difficulté nous avons dû
affronter une situation de crise
particulièrement difficile aujourd'hui
nous avons besoin d'être chaude et de
nous sentir considérés et ce type
d'image sont destructrices
- demain je dois rencontrer les médecins
les infirmières les manipulateurs radio
tout le personnel qui travaille à
l'hôpital à tous les niveaux il nous
devons avoir un discours de respect
envers eux et ces images là ça ne
traduit pas le respect que toute la
france a témoigné aux soignants je me
reproche pas la folie à la police
fait son travail je pense que la police
a fait correctement son travail mais il
ya des décisions qui devraient être
prises en amont pour garantir le droit
des soignants à présenter leurs
revendications
alors quand on vous entend on a
l'impression que vous êtes surpris par
la manière dont cette manifestation a
dégénéré aujourd'hui on a eu on a pu
entendre gérard raymond qu'est le
président de france à sa santé je crois
que nous expliquer que lui n'était pas
du tout surpris par cette situation
qu'il fallait maintenant trouver
d'autres moyens par entendre sa voix et
que ce genre de manifestation ce n'était
plus l'idéal aujourd'hui oui
probablement il a raison la société
change est aujourd'hui à d'autres modes
de revendications c'est un empêche que
c'est un élément culturel en france nous
restons encore attaché à un certain
nombre de manifestations ce que je
respecte beaucoup de soignants beaucoup
de nos communautés citoyens considèrent
cet endroit et c'est un droit garanti
par la constitution que de pouvoir
manifester
donc je leur accorde ce droit
probablement ce n'est plus aussi
efficace que dans le temps puisque
effectivement maintenant c'est
parfaitement détournée et nc -
contre-productif
je pense que nous les soignants le
message que nous devons passer cette
mission au service de la population pour
rien n'est plus important pour nous de
continuer à assurer nos missions a
soigné notation à être à leur
disposition que s'il y avait une
nouvelle et différente ce que j'espère
sa femme sera pas le cas nous aurons
toujours disponible nous serons toujours
à la hauteur des attentes de la
population
parce que nous sommes à leurs services
c'est ça le message des soignants en
même temps il est légitime de dire que
nous avons des grosses difficultés
statutaire nous avons dû
ce difficultés salariales que dans
certaines villes se loger est devenu
tellement cher qu il y à une rupture
totale entre le salaire et la capacité
de se loger à proximité de son lieu de
travail ce qui crée des problèmes
majeurs dans les hôpitaux
compte tenu de nos horaires compte tenu
d'un mode de fonctionnement et il doit y
en a des réponses et que nous attendons
sa réponse de la part du gouvernement
mais en aucun cas nous ne pouvons
accepter que une manifestation des
soignants qui est incapable de traduire
un certain nombre de messages soient
prises en otage par un des individus qui
pour moi n'ont aucune légitimité
aucun droit de s'exprimer au nom des
soignants et en aucun cas ont le droit
nous mettrons donges et nous soignons
qui de façon légitime présente une
revendication et les ont mis en danger
ces individus le jour qui viendront à
l'hôpital il faut qu'ils sachent que
nous sommes aussi où nous occuper d'eux
pour nous occuper de leurs familles et
de leurs proches et que en faisant ce
qu'ils ont fait aujourd'hui nous ont mis
en danger
ils ont mis en danger des personnes qui
ont pour destiné pour toutes leurs lui
le sens de leur mission et de l'an viii
est d'être au service des autres
personnes ce n'est pas acceptable et
bellino on va rejoindre on va faire le
point sur le thème mon argent dans un
instant notre reporter mais j'ai une
question
vous parlez de l'épidémie pardonnez moi
cette question mais est-ce que c'est
raisonnable cette journée d'action
nationale
alors qu'on est encore en phase finale
finale de déconfinement oui je pense que
ce n'est pas forcément une très bonne
idée dans son réunira plus
jour milliers de personnes dans la rue
et de ne pas respecter les exclus et les
règles de distanciation c'est évident
côté de ça le conseil d'état a rappelé
que c'est un droit et que les gens
peuvent eux usé de ce droit
donc je me remets à la loi et chacun
d'entre nous doit se remettre à la loi
mais c'est inacceptable j'insiste que
des gens ne respectant pas la loi et ne
respecte pas les droits des soignants de
pouvoir manifester dans une ambiance
sereine sans se mettre en danger et sans
pouvoir exprimer leurs légitimes
revendications
merci elle risquait casalino chef des
urgences à l'hôpital bichat on va
retrouver lit la fameuse ou qui suit
pour nous cette manifestation lille afin
quelle est la situation sur place
maintenant
alors ici je me trouve près du métro des
invalides et finalement l'ambiance ici
ressemble à celle du début de cette
manifestation c'est à dire festive en
soleil et avec beaucoup de musique art
puisque la manifestation ici est en
train de se terminer
les manifestants se dispersent les
forces de l'ordre ont sommé le public
ici donc 2 à quitter les lieux
et d'ailleurs je suis avec linda bigot
qui est une figure des gilet jaune qui a
tenu à ce qu'est un maximum de chez les
jeunes qui viennent ici aujourd'hui pour
montrer leur soutien au personnel
soignant
finalement vous m'avez dit tout à
l'heure quand on parlait il fallait
dépasser les applaudissements sur les
balcons à 20h pour soutenir les
personnels soyons mais venir leur
montrer vraiment le soutien de toute la
population française aujourd'hui
effectivement pendant le confinement
toute la population française en
majorité applaudit tous les soirs à 20h
le personnel soignant qui étaient au
front de véritables héros à soigner
l'ensemble de la population en mettant
en jeu leur famille leur vie avec très
peu de moyens et donc c'était je pense
effectivement légitime d'être là
aujourd'hui de leur montrer notre
connaissance de les soutenir au travers
de leurs revendications
je tiens à rappeler que nous gilet jaune
avant l'année dernière au mois de mai
organisé une manifestation en soutien
aux personnels soignants
nous avons été lors de nos
manifestations précurseur d' alerte en
lançant c'est à l'air que ce soit pour
le personnel soignant
que ce soit pour l'éducation nationale
contre la loi bancaire que ce soit pour
les retraites pour les blessés des
violences policières que nous avons
subies donc aujourd'hui un an plus tard
le constat est là justement qu'est-ce
que vous répondez à ceux qui pourraient
éventuellement accusé aujourd'hui les
gilet jaune de vouloir se greffer un
mouvement un peu plus large pour c'est
pour essayer de grandir un peu leur rend
pas du tout alors personnellement j'ai
été en contact avec certains membres de
l'organisation de cet appel aujourd'hui
nous n'avons pas souhaité déclaré parce
que c'était leur événement mais ils ont
accepté qu'on soit là en soutien alors
là vous venez de revenir sur toutes les
fois où vous avez effectivement appelé
les gens à se mobiliser depuis le 17
novembre 2018 il faut le rappeler quand
même vous avez des noms c'est
effectivement ce que vous considérez
comme une casse sociale ici en france
est-ce que vous avez l'impression
quelque part les jets les jaunes ont été
précurseurs ont été en avance sur une
colère nationale dans le pays mais
complètement complètement dès que
monsieur mac on est arrivés au pouvoir
nous avons tout de suite constaté qu' il
nous mentait dès le départ qu'ils
n'avaient qui n'allait pas tenir ses
promesses
il a dit qu'il ne toucherait pas aux
retraites et ben un an plus tard on voit
que c'est pas le cas
le code du travail pareil le service
public est déjà à l'agonie avant qu'il
vienne au pouvoir il l'a asphyxié encore
plus alors quoi de plus légitime pour la
population que de sortir tous ensemble
main dans la main et sauvé nos
institutions parce qu'on en a besoin
dernière question une d'habibou quitte à
leur m'avait dit avant ce direct que
finalement vous étiez un peu triste de
la manière dont ces manifestations
avaient un peu dégénéré à un moment et
qu'ils aient finalement oublié le
message de départ de cette mobilisation
et bas ce qui est triste c'est que à
chaque fois depuis quelques mois
peu importe le mouvement protestataire
qui se passe dans la rue on se confronte
ajustement de la violence policière
un maintien de l'ordre qui n'est pas du
maintien de l'ordre puisque le droit de
co de manifester est complètement
aliénés
moi ce que je comprends pas ok d'accord
la police doit maintenir l'ordre
mais pourquoi venir intervenir pendant
le déroulement d'une manifestation
et on peut le constater peu importe que
ce soit chez ligier les jaunes que ce
soit peu importe la manifestation
organisée on l'a encore vu samedi
alors on est toujours là braqués les
caméras vers soi disant ceci ou cela
mais moi je braque la caméra vers les
forces de l'ordre et les donneurs
d'ordre une manifestation peut bien se
passer
à partir du moment où les forces de
l'ordre tiennent leur distance répond à
nos questions
vous entendez ça m'en tape comme on le
disait tout à l'heure la situation a
dégénéré
effectivement plusieurs fois pendant
cette manifestation qui avait bien
commencé qui se termine pour le moment
dans le calme en tout cas là où je me
trouve près du métro des invalides où on
avait effectivement plusieurs personnes
sortir de ce pré carré qui était au
monde était menacé depuis maintenant
plusieurs heures finalement le soleil
est revenu après un petit passage
pluvieux le soleil revenu la musique
aussi est là pour l'instant l'ambiance
est plutôt bonne il n'y a plus
d'affrontements entre les forces de
l'ordre et les manifestants
en tout cas ceux qui restent ici sur
cette place merci la femme au zoo donc
on approche de la dispersion ça c'est
visiblement calmés
on va vous retrouver tout à l'heure pour
faire un nouveau point on retrouve notre
invité henrique casalino chef des
urgences à l'hôpital bichat
merci de réagir en direct avec nous sur
les recettes et france ô
cette journée d'action nationale elle
coïncide aussi avec une journée
importante puisque c'est cette idée
normalement à 17 heures que vous devez
commencer les auditions de la commission
parlementaire à l'assemblée nationale
avec la première audition de jérôme
salomon le directeur général de la santé
donc une journée importante à double
titre
oui je pense que c'est vraiment
important
nous avons dit que nous avons tous
travaillé
nous avons été je pense très réactif
l'hôpital a fait preuve d'une capacité
d'adaptation et de flexibilité pour
pouvoir répondre aux besoins de la
population liés aux convives tout en
continuant à assurer en continuant à
assurer ses missions habituelles la
prise en charge des patients qui
n'avaient pas le kobina mais qu'il
fallait continuer à prendre en charge
c'est normal qu'il y ait des auditions
convoi où il a une des difficultés
qu'est ce qu'on peut améliorer son lait
enseignement les points faibles les
points forts que nous pouvons tirer de
cette expérience et qui nous servent
pour des pour l'avenir savez le risque
de nouveaux agents infectieux est un
disque aurait elle le convive nous l'a
enseigné ou l'a rappelé le risque de
modification et de nouveaux risques liés
à aux changements climatiques
c'est aussi quelque chose de concret de
réel donc c'est essentiel que nous
apprenions de nos erreurs et que nous
apprenions aussi des bonnes choses qui
ont été faites
comment nous pouvons mieux répondre un
prochain épisode qui pourrait arriver à
n'importe quel moment dans quelques mois
dans quelques années personne ne le sait
oui notre travail consiste à toujours
être prêt toujours être en état de
répondre un nouveau risque un nouveau
danger
mais concrètement cette commission
denquête un parlementaire elle vise à à
cibler les défaillances dans cette
gestion de la crise défaillance de la
part du gouvernement dans cette gestion
de la crise sanitaire
là vous attendez quoi concrètement
je pense qu'une commission d'enquêté n'a
pas pour objectif d'identifier
uniquement les erreurs qu est ce qu elle
se noie jambon sur d'autres objectifs
et si elle part du principe qu'elle ne
va identifier que des erreurs n'étaient
pas objective donc une commission une
commission parlementaire comme dans
toute structure qui fait des enquêtes
elle ferait elle mène une enquête à
charge par les charges elles mêmes une
enquête pour savoir qu'est ce qui s'est
bien passée où il a eu des erreurs moi
je trouve qu'un des éléments importants
de cette épidémie
c'est que nous avons montré les
soignants à quel point nous étions
réactif à quel point notre travail a du
sens pour nous à quel point chaque
soignant a été prêt à s'exposer à se
mettre en danger à être réactif à être
hyper disponibles
bayer d euros + et nous avons été
capables de montrer que la valeur
principale du système hospitalier
ce sont ces personnes ce sont les
membres de cette communauté et c'est la
communauté ne voit pas opposé des
médecins avec le médecin des directeurs
ou du personnel administratif
nous travaillons tous la main dans la
main sont les directeurs sont le
personnel administratif sans les
soignants que ce soit des médecins des
paramédicaux sur 100 le personnel qui
assure la logistique
on savait arrivée à l'hôpital erasme
blouson propre nécessite de mobiliser
les moyens considérables humains et
matériels toutes les personnes qui
travaillent sur ces filières logistique
sont essentielles et ils font partie de
notre équipe
toutes ces personnes se sont mobilisées
chacun dans son poste chacun a été
capable aussi d'aller au delà de 100
postes pour montrer qu'il était capable
on travaillait dans l'intérêt
d'atteindre la mission qui vous est
confiée qui est une autre mission de
soignants et c'est ça qui a permis la
grandeur de la réponse dans notre
système hospitalier
ça n'a pas été uniquement une question
d'argent ça a été une question d'être
humain d'un personnes que nous
partagions des valeurs alors ça c'est
vrai que au coeur des sujets qui sont
posés sur la table dans le cadre du
ségur de la santé évidemment ce plan
massif d'investissements et de
revalorisation promis par le président
de la république
qu'est-ce qui est qu'est ce qui vous
semble le plus important c'est forcément
la revalorisation des salaires
pour commencer je pense que la révolte
la revalorisation des salaires est
quelque chose d'essentiel
parce que ça a été dit et si aujourd'hui
on ne le faisait pas ce serait une
erreur monstrueuse
la deuxième chose c'est qu'au augmenter
l'attractivité de nos métiers et pour
augmenter l'attractivité de nos métiers
il faut créer des statuts qui soit
attractif des et carrière
professionnelle pour chacun d'entre nous
ils sont attractifs redonner du sens à
notre métier ce n'est pas simplement
mieux payés
c'est aussi mieux et mieux considérés
dans les structures hospitalières et en
dehors
avoir des parcours qui vous permet
d'allier du privé vers le public et
pouvoir avoir une carrière riche
intéressante avec des perspectives
d'évolution
tout ça c'est le véritable défi que nous
avons devant nous c'est pas simplement
une question de dire je vais mettre plus
de lits et quelques milliards en plus il
faut redonner du sens à notre travail
il faut reconnaître que une personne
peut évoluer tout au long de ses 35 ans
de métier
avant d'arriver à la retraite et qu' il
faut lui donner une certaine souplesse
dans le dispositif
il faut reconnaître ses compétences les
accroître
il l'accompagné dans son évolution c'est
ça le véritable défi aujourd'hui nous
avons les postes vacants à l'hôpital
nous avons des postes d'infirmières qui
sont d'accord dans nos hôpitaux
ça c'est lié au fait que nous ne sommes
pas assez attractif pour donner envie
aux jeunes de faire ce type de métier
donc travaillons tous ensemble la main
dans la main pour trouver les bonnes
réponses les bonnes solutions
merci beaucoup
à vous pour avoir réagi en direct sur
arte france merci on va rejoindre on va
faire un point sur le terrain maintenant
avec vous katia technique qu'elle est
quelle est la situation normalement on
approche de 2k tiens on va pas pouvoir
vous retrouver tout de suite on va vous
trouver un petit peu plus tard si vous
m'entendez
enfin voila mais je n'ai pas j'ai perdu
nico dakar locaux ok oui je ne fais que
bédié pour vous 4 ap coupe mais c'est
compliqué pour vous katia technique je
sais pas si on peut vous prendront part
ou nous dit ce que ça s'agite pas mal
autour de vous on approche de la
dispersion sera confus
[Applaudissements]
sinon vous reprendre un petit peu plus
tard katia technique on va vous
reprendre plus tard caezar prenez moi
putain
d'accord on va revoir tout à l'heure je
vois que c'est très très difficile pour
vous parce que c'est confus c'est une
journée donc un de mobilisation des
personnels soignants à paris aux
invalides dans toute la france également
une journée d'action nationale est à
paris a eu donc des échauffourées des
heurts entre les forces de l'ordre et
des manifestants avec des profils
radicaux des black blocks aussi qui ont
semé le trouble en marge de cette
manifestation plus de 220 rassemblements
dans toute la france et plusieurs
milliers de personnes rassemblées dans
la capitale du côté des invalides on
voit ici donc ces images en direct où
les forces de l'ordre qui interviennent
maintenant depuis plusieurs heures pour
tenter de maîtriser les individus au qui
sème le trouble
et puis dispersés aussi cette
manifestation ça va être quand même le
point le plus délicat en fait fin
d'après midi ont fait le point avec vous
nadège abderrazak vous êtes également au
coeur de ce cortège
comment se déroule cette fin d'après
midi cette dispersion
[Musique]
mais écoutez samantha cette
manifestation elle touche à sa fin il
reste plus que quelques centaines de
manifestants et c'est sur cette place
des invalides est les forces de l'ordre
sont désormais en supériorité numérique
et ils ont appelé les manifestants à
quitter les lieux en prenant le métro
est des invalides mais cette dispersion
elle se fait de manière quelque peu
tendue puisque les manifestants qui
restent sont pacifiques et la souhaite
en fait poursuivre leur mobilisation
jusqu'à son terme et 18h 18h30 les
forces de l'ordre ne sont pas forcément
d'accord donc vous le voyez un sur ces
deux images de julien de la cour on a
plusieurs effectifs de police qui sont
désormais mobilisés sur cette place des
invalides et qui demandent de manière
ciblée aux manifestants de quitter les
lieux certains écoutent
d'autres n'ont donc on a vu certains
policiers et bien a demandé de manière
un peu plus forte et bien aux
manifestants de quitter les lieux
certains ont reçu des coups de matraque
pour l'instant ça s'est calmé mais bon
on a comme habituellement comme c'est le
cas habituellement à des épisodes 2 de
tension qui varie avec des épisodes de
d'accalmie voilà donc je le disais
quelques une petite poignée maintenant
de manifestants présents sur cette place
des invalides
elle s'est terminée cette manifestation
à les organisations syndicales sont
partis depuis un moment
donc voilà on compte plusieurs dizaines
de blessés alors de cette manifestation
en soutien à l'hôpital public médecins
infirmiers aides soignants ont fait le
déplacement
aujourd'hui au départ du ministère de la
santé
ils avaient prévu de manifester jusqu'à
l'assemblée nationale et ça n'a pas été
possible cette manifestation elle se
termine ici à place des invalides ou
deux noms
aux affrontements éclatés tout au long
de l'après-midi entre manifestants et
certains entre manifestants et forces de
l'ordre
et parmi les manifestants figuraient
plusieurs centaines voire milliers
d'éléments radicaux habillés de noir
masqués cagoulés qui est et bien sont
venus pour vous pour garder l'intérêt
qu'elle va rejoindre un invité
christophe prudhomme qui est médecin
urgentiste au samu responsable cgt
l'adage on va vous retrouver tout à
l'heure bonjour christophe prudhomme
mais c'est d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france comment vous réagissez à
cette journée d'action à paris
particulièrement émaillée par des heures
d entre certains manifestants et les
forces de l'ordre
écoutez ce qui est important c'est que
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
personnes ont manifesté aujourd'hui en
france dont 220 rassemblements physique
plus des manifestations dans les
hôpitaux des rassemblements pour nos
collègues qui est au travail et qui sont
rassemblés à 20-30 minutes sur leur
temps de pause en ce qui concerne les
incidents à paris
écoutez moi j'aimerais bien que vous
médias vous posiez la question au préfet
l'allemand ou préfète paris qui est très
contesté sur la raison pour laquelle
quelques dizaines quelques mois j'étais
sur la manifestation
ils étaient très peu nombreux ces
agitateurs
pourquoi la police les laisse agir pour
qu'ensuite dans les médias au lieu de
parler des revendications de la
manifestation vous fassiez vous tourner
en boucle sur les affrontements à la fin
de la manifestation
c'était ce qui s'était passé quand les
manifestations pour les retraites est là
de nouveau ça se pose pourquoi
quelles sont les consignes données à la
police moi je pose le problème on
regarde ce qui s'est passé ces dernières
années et de la position du préfet
l'allemand moi je fais partie de ceux
qui posent la question pourquoi ce
préfet reste en poste alors qu'il est
contesté et que régulièrement nous avons
des incidents des manifestations où la
police
statique res laisse ces éléments brûler
des voitures agir sans que la police
n'intervienne au bon moment voilà moi
j'étais sur place et je pose cette
question et je remets en cause
effectivement les consignes qui sont de
la police secrète
christophe prudhomme vous pointez là et
c'est vrai une situation que l'on
observe dans bon nombre de
manifestations avec les gilet jaune mais
pas seulement
on a vu que lors des dernières
manifestations contre les violences
policières et le racisme présumées au
sein des forces de l'ordre
c'était aussi compliqué c'est une
situation qui est récurrente mais c'est
aussi compliqué pour les forces de
l'ordre qui sont mobilisés soumis à rude
épreuve semaine après semaine ce qui est
ce quelqu'un qui faut-il pointer les
responsabilités
je ne pointe pas les responsabilités des
policiers qui sont sur place
c'est pas le problème ils sont
effectivement mis dans des situations
très difficiles du fait désordre qui
leur sont données voyez moi lors de
manifestations pacifiques
j'ai eu affaire à ces matchs brigades
volantes de policiers sur moto et
quitter ce n'est pas une police
républicaine
voilà c'est ça le problème aujourd'hui
quelles sont les consignes qui sont
données à la police par le préfet
l'allemand pourquoi y at-il toujours des
incidents dans les manifestations avec
quelques dizaines parfois quelques
centaines d'agitateurs
nous étions plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de manifestants
la manifestation s'est très bien passé
nous avons demandé la dispersion il
reste encore quelques personnes sur les
pelouse
il fait beau mais pourquoi
systématiquement y at il des incidents
qui permettent à vous médias de les
passer en boucle pour pouvoir parler
d'autre chose que de la journée d'action
très massives avec des revendications
qui sont précises concernant l'hôpital
c'est beaucoup plus important que ces
quelques incidents
nous demandons aujourd'hui ça fait trois
semaines qu'on vous amuse avec le sigle
santé nous demandons des réponses du
ministre et nous avons posé un ultimatum
ministre en tout cas nous les
organisations syndicales on doit leur
encontre
on doit honda demandé qu'il soit présent
la place mme notât vendredi prochain et
qui viennent avec des réponses
financièrement non au minimum 15
milliards d'euros immédiatement pour
répondre aux revendications concernant
les effectifs et les salaires
sa part yves sur d'importantes mais
c'est ce qu'a proposé le gouvernement il
ya quelques jours uniquement pour un
secteur d'activité qu'à l'industrie
aéronautique est ce que l'hôpital le
secteur de santé et d'action sociale
n'est pas aussi important que le secteur
aéronautique
et pourquoi le gouvernement ne nous
donne aucun chiffre
aucune somme aucun moyen supplémentaire
pour l'hôpital alors que ça fait trois
semaines que l'on participe à des pseudo
réunion voilà la colère elle est là
après le problème de la police et du
préfet l'allemand crois que ça soit
réglé par le président de la république
par ministère de l'intérieur il ya un
véritable problème
christophe prudhomme qui vous parlez des
médias est vrai qu'on passe en boucle
ces images de manifestations et ses
heures mais c'est aussi l'occasion et on
l'a vu tout au long de cet après-midi
d'entendre aussi des manifestants et on
a mis aussi en avant ces manifestants
ainsi que leurs revendications c'est ce
que vous faites également puisque vous
parlez des des 15 milliards d'euros que
vous vous attendez le gouvernement ils
vous donnent rendez vous
au mois de juillet justement pour fixer
les modalités
les en tout cas donner des réponses aux
questions que vous vous posez et que
tous les patients le pose à ce
gouvernement là concrètement vous vous
attendez vous au mois de juillet des
réponses concrètes
non mais juillet c'est trop tard madame
nous avons déjà prévu deux nouvelles
journées d'action parce que nous sommes
dans grève depuis un an un an
les quatorze gouvernement s'ils nous
donnent pas de réponse c'est qu'il veut
pas nous donner une réponse
donc c'est que c'est non donc nous
allons nous avons déjà prévu d'autres
journées d'action
je pense qu'ils seront encore plus
puissante que celle d'aujourd'hui le 30
à la fin du mois et le 14 juillet parce
que nous n'acceptons pas nous
n'acceptons pas que monsieur macron nous
instrumentaliser en nous proposant de
défilés ou d'aller une sauterie le 14
juillet nous serons présents le 14
juillet sur les champs elysées aux blues
pour dire monsieur macro ce ne sont pas
des médailles
une blonde ce ne sont pas des cérémonies
et des solos défilé du 14 juillet ce
sont des réponses à nos revendications
nous ne sommes pas des héros nous sommes
les salariés qui demandent ont des
moyens pour travailler dans de bonnes
conditions
voilà le message qu'on veut faire passer
est ce que pour terminer donc vous
donner rendez vous le 30 juin et le 14
juillet ce 14 juillet qui devait être
une journée en tout cas fait ce qu a
annoncé l'elysée en hommage au personnel
soignant est ce que là vous comprenez
aussi ses convergences que l'on retrouve
au sein de ces manifestations il ya des
gilets jaunes que l'on voit il ya
évidemment beaucoup de syndicats aussi
c'est cette convergence vous vous
l'acceptez cette convergence mais cette
convergence nous l'avons construite
c'est pas qu'on accepte
nous l'avons construit vous savez que
nous travaillons syndicats collectifs
associations de patients main dans la
main depuis maintenant de très nombreux
mois
donc c'est le résultat de cette
convergence la mobilisation massive
aujourd'hui
ensuite effectivement le mouvement à
l'hôpital et la suite des gilet jaune
mais je veux dire là le problème c'est
pas les gilet jaune qui sont à l'origine
des incidents les quelques gilet jaune
qui était présent dans la manifestation
ce sont des gens qui viennent dans les
manifestations pour pourrir la fin des
manifestations c'est leur choix
politique
nous le considérons que nous n'avons
rien à faire avec eux il faut que la
police fasse son travail pour que les
manifestations ne se termine pas
systématiquement par ces incidents
quito longue dans les médias français et
étrangers c'est quand même étonnant
voyez d'accord oui vous nous donnez la
parole pour qu'on puisse parler de nos
revendications
vous serez je regarde y compris la
télévision russe de temps en temps parce
que j'ai une belle fille qui est russe
hélas elle passe en boucle dans les
manifestations quoi les incidents en
permanence de trois voitures qui brûlent
de trois scooters qui brûlent voyez
c'est de la manipulation cette affaire
et moi je fais partie de ceux qui posent
la question aujourd'hui est ce que le
préfet l'allemand doit rester en poste
au regard au regard de tous ces
dysfonctionnements qui sont pointés par
les organisations syndicales par les
organisations citoyennes d'avoir
interdit la manifestation et d'avoir
stocké plus de 10 des délais plus de
cent mille personnes sur la place de la
république samedi
c'est une faute à tout point de vue tant
au niveau de l'ordre public trudaine
s'était pas non plus à l'avantagé des
forces de l'ordre et des autorités de
voir ces images tournaient en boucle un
aurait coûté si ça parce que stade et
considèrent les manifestations
sade et considèrent les manifestations
voilà moi je considère que c'est de la
manipulation
c'est de la manipulation pour des
considérer les manifestations quand on
parle de ça on parle pas d'autre chose
et ça renforce effectivement les mesures
autoritaires pour qu'elle soit acceptée
par une partie de la population
voilà donc la problématique fait la
présence effectivement des black blocks
d'individus radicalisés au sein de deux
manifestations
celle ci mais on a vu également que ça
arrive est très souvent lors des
manifestations des gilet jaune par
exemple merci à vous je rappelle que
vous êtes mes frères urgentiste au samu
responsable cgt on va retrouver
justement un gilet jaune aux côtés de
l'île afin amouzou lit la fac est
entouré de quelques gilet jaune lui la
femme ouzou quelle est la situation de
votre côté également
écoutez ici en tout cas au niveau du
métro invalides la situation et festive
dans la situation est revenue au calme
mais pour tout vous dire tout à l'heure
j'étais en train de parler avec notre
invité qui à côté de moi il chamkhi un
gilet jaune
en fait on se disait que c'était un
calme qui al'air précaire c'est à dire
qu'on a vu il ya à peine dix minutes une
charge des forces de l'ordre des
tensions entre des forces de l'ordre et
les manifestants on est totalement nas
est ici c'est impossible de sortir de ce
pré carré et effectivement je vous dis
on sent que les choses pourraient
dégénérer assez rapidement comme on le
disait tout à l'heure et cham donc vous
vous êtes gilet jaune depuis le début du
mouvement
vous étiez là vous êtes là aujourd'hui
parce que c'était important pour vous de
montrer votre soutien au personnel
soignant
bien sûr donc comme vous l'avez dit au
départ je suis gilet jaune depuis le
début du mouvement
aujourd'hui je tenais à la fois marquer
ma sympathie avec le mouvement
hospitalier parce que
on voit bien que le discours de notre
président il ya eu beaucoup de mensonges
ou n'a pas pu dire honnêtement à nous le
peuple français qui l'a mal gérée
il a eu l'intelligence et de 10 rebonds
effectivement j'ai peut-être pris ça à
la légère
je suis désolé on va voir comment on va
améliorer les choses
non pour vous en fait finalement
aujourd'hui c'est la continuité d'un
combat c'est un bras de fer qui se
poursuit en fait effectivement mais ce
que je veux dire on utilise et j'aime
pas trop ce terme là parce que conti
combat donc il ya forcément un rapport
de force et a depuis le début nous les
gilet jaune on est pacifiste
on est là pour revendiquer nos acquis et
les défendre mais tout en restant
pacifiste n'y a pas de combat le combat
il est en face parce qu'on veut nous
faire taire on veut faire taire cette
nouvelle génération de contestataires on
veut faire taire la population qui donne
demande à ce que c'est nos élus nous
rendent des comptes
on n'est pas dans la toute puissance
le gouvernement ne peut pas s'inscrire
dans la petite puissance on nous doit
des comptes et ses comptes
il faut nous les rendre justement vous
parlez de combat vous parlez de force
on a quand même vu clairement un rapport
de force aujourd'hui pendant cette
manifestation avec les forces de l'ordre
et des groupes de manifestants qui ont
régulièrement
d'ailleurs c'est les manifestants qui
ont commencé pas forcément les soignants
mais des jeunes qu'on a vu cagoulés
habillés en noir qui ont commencé à
lancer des projectiles sur des forces de
l'ordre qui étaient plutôt stoïque au
début et qui ont commencé à riposter au
bout d'un moment quand même mais moi je
vais juste vous donner une phrase quand
ya pas de justice
ça pousse à l'insurrection
donc ces jeunes il demande de la justice
il demande qu'une justice sociale de
justice fiscale c'est ça qu'on réclame
et est aujourd'hui moi je suis heureux
je suis heureux parce que je n'ai jamais
vu autant de jeunes
ah ça fait deux ans que tu dors j'ai
jamais vu autant de jeunes sortir depuis
ces trois dernières semaines
et d'ailleurs je tenais à tous les
féliciter vous êtes sorti les gars
maintenant il va falloir vous inscrire
va falloir apprendre pour ne pas tomber
dans le rapport de force dans lequel on
veut nous inscrire pour les pacifistes
on aime nous mêmes notre pays on aime
nos concitoyens on aime nos voisins le
hors de question de sortir pour taper
sur son voisin
voilà bien merci d'avoir plein de
questions cham vous entendez ça monte à
des manifestions qu'ils restent
déterminés même s'ils ont l'impression
c'est une journée mobilisation a été un
peu on va dire détériorés par les
violences qui a eu et qu'on a relaté
tout au long de l'après-midi en tout cas
maintenant à l'heure où je vous parle
devant le métro au niveau du métro des
invalides
la situation est très calme festive
ensoleillé il ya des manifestions qui
sont encore là en très grand nombre
quand même et des forces de l'ordre qui
nast totalement s'étendre en tout cas où
je me trouve mais pas de tension notable
en tout cas à vous signaler à cette
heure-ci où je vous parle
merci la fin vous ou manifestations
journée d'action nationale à paris mais
aussi on l'a dit tout au long de cet
après midi en province un de paris à
montpellier en passant par metz
dunkerque toulouse marseille on va voir
on va se rendre du
côté de rennes où là bas aussi dans la
rue en a manifesté plus de 2000
personnes pour étaient sur place pour
défendre l'hôpital public dans le cadre
de cette journée de mobilisation
nationale contrairement à la capitale
sur 13000 ces stations elle s'est
déroulée
vous voyez dans le calme on va écouter
la parole du personnel soignant présent
là bas on a été soutenu par la
population n'a été soutenue par le
gouvernement beaucoup beaucoup de
discours et là il ya un retour à la
normale trois mois après nous on attend
voilà d'avoir des vraies mesures qu'ils
soient qu'ils soient qu'ils soient
prises en charge pour nous pas pour le
patient pour la santé publique en fait
faut savoir que les salaires sont quand
même gelé depuis dix ans donc nous on
n'avait jamais eu d'augmentation de
salaire pour vous donner un exemple ça
fait 12 ans que chez infirmière je suis
payé 1780 euros net par mois en étant
titulaire depuis plus de dix ans et en
travaillant le week end
ces médailles on a décidé d'être
acheteur mais symboliquement un objet de
revendications puisque évidemment par
rapport aux besoins réels de l'hôpital
elle ne nous servira à rien les seules
choses qui vont nous servir
c'est plus de lits plus de postes les
recrutements massifs pour faire face à
aux besoins des populations
évidemment des salaires 300 euros pour
toutes et tous
vrai voilà pour ces manifestations
recueillis à reims en province où tout
s'est passé plutôt dans le calme
on a eu une 4000 manifestants à bordeaux
3500 à marseille selon des chiffres de
la police à la mi-journée
ces images en direct à paris où on est
toujours on approche en tout cas de la
dispersion sinal les forces de l'ordre
qui sont toujours présents voyez c'est
ce corps dont deux fourgons des forces
de fonds de l'aide des forces de l'ordre
on va rejoindre rachid digoin qui est
infirmier au bloc opératoire du centre
hospitalier william morey président du
collectif inter blocs dont jours à vous
merci est d'être en direct avec nous
votre réaction à cette journée de heurts
dans la capitale lors de cette journée
de mobilisation
écoutez je découvre les images un peu en
rond puisque moi je n'étais plus tôt en
local ou à vous ça s'est très bien passé
où il ya eu une manifestation plutôt
pacifique
malheureusement c'est je pense des
dérives limité puisque lloris ne font
pas les soignants qui sont qui sont mis
en cause mais bon malheureusement ça
fait partie des mouvements anglais des
droits sociaux on le regrette
malheureusement ça entache un peu là la
forte mobilisation théo aujourd'hui
c'est dommage sur les revendications des
personnels soignants cette journée elle
est importante à quelles raisons en ce
moment il se passe le sait du rhin où a
priori tout tout se joue malheureusement
on ne sait pas partie de la liste des
invités nous avons été sollicités au
départ pour le lancement mais
malheureusement on été mis sur la touche
notamment une grosse partie des
organisations à ces rumeurs on le
regrette aujourd'hui c'était important
de se mobiliser de de manifester notre
notre colère ce qu'aujourd'hui c'est ce
qui prédomine c'est la colère des
soignants et d'être dans la rue et
d'imposer de revendiquer un rapport de
force par rapport à ce gouvernement qui
nous méprise depuis depuis trop
longtemps
ce gouvernement qui tente en tout cas de
trouver des solutions à tous azimuts on
sait qu'on traverse ne traversent
toujours cette crise sanitaire
à cela s'ajoute une crise économique
d'envergure
on est dans un cas de figure qui est
quand même différent par rapport au
début de l'année ou même avant lorsque
vous avez des revendications c'est vrai
que la crise économique elle frappe fort
le gouvernement il a publié ce week end
et décret qui entérine le versement
d'une prime exceptionnelle admis l'année
500 euros pour les salariés des ehpad
une majoration également de 50% des
heures supplémentaires effectuées à
l'hôpital qui seront normalement payer
avant le mois de septembre sur ces
mesures qui interviennent avant les
réponses attendues en juillet qu'est ce
que vous dites
la prime malheureusement c'est parce
qu'on réclame depuis le début on sait
très bien que cette prime allait
distribuer de façon injuste nous c'était
des revendications ça des
revalorisations salariales concours pour
réclame depuis le début des
mobilisations
vous dites que le contexte est
particulier malheureusement le coc vide
il a mis en évidence toute la structure
qui a qui s'écoulait de l'hôpital public
voilà c'est ça que encore retient
aujourd'hui c'est pas c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui ça fait dix quinze vingt
ans que on pioche dans les caisses de
l'hôpital public pour l'assainir
aujourd'hui c'est la crise du cog hill
qui est qui qui reflète tout ce manque
est malheureusement on peut pas dire que
c'est que t'as foutu kobina on voit que
les hôpitaux sont en cellule depuis bien
trop longtemps
et cette colère elle et voilà elle est
dissimulée par tous à l'est la crise du
coc vide justement elle fait l'objet
d'auditions en cours lors d'une d'une
commission d'enquêté parlementaire à
l'assemblée nationale
commission qui a débuté ses travaux cet
après midi à 17 heures avec l'audition
de jérôme salomon le directeur général
de la santé là encore ça coïncide aussi
avec cette journée d'action nationale
c'est un hasard du calendrier ou pas
vous pensez je pensais hasard du
calendrier je pense qu'elle était prévue
depuis depuis bien plus longtemps
nous ce qu'on par rapport à ces ascètes
entier temps on a le collectif inter
bloc a mis une plainte au pénal sur 32
établissements 32 chu en france puisque
on compte bien avoir un retour au niveau
des comtés de tout ce qui s'est passé
tous les manquements auquel on a fait ça
c'est notamment au face aux équipes pros
manque d'équipements de protection
très bien merci beaucoup à vous pour
avoir réagi en direct sur eyrieux france
rachid digoit infirmé au bloc opératoire
du centre hospitalier william morey
président du collectif interbox vous
restez peut-être avec nous on va vous
retrouver dans un instant mais avant on
va voir du côté de katia près cnic qui
suisse au portage avec une ambiance qui
le calme semblait être revenu katia on
voit même des manifestants dansent et
derrière vous
alors oui alors sa danse mais enfin la
menace se resserre oui j'ai pas si vous
nicolas voeckler un peu montré que d'un
côté il ya de la danse et de l'autre
côté la nasse qui se resserre regardé
par là donc voilà les si vous voulez les
forces de l'ordre les forces de l'ordre
sont en train d'avancer au fur et à
mesure comme vous le savez une série de
charges extrêmement violente avec des
éléments provocateurs
d'un côté le black block les
manifestants citoyens venus et pour les
soignants et puis les soignants venus en
nombre
il aurait s'il ya ici des gilet jaune il
ya ici des soignants il ya ici des
personnes
mais soutenir et justement dans cette
scène assez incongrue après la
afin la manif juste avant la dispersion
je suis avec al faveur vous êtes aide
soignante vous êtes aussi gilet jaune
alors dites nous quel bilan vous tiré de
cette manifestation aujourd'hui à cette
manifestation je contente parce qu'on a
eu
voilà à quoi beaucoup de spitalier
beaucoup de citoyens donc voilà ça fait
plaisir parce qu'on est soutenu en fait
voilà on n'a pas été abandonné par la
population le fait que yi beaucoup
d'échauffourées est-ce que ça a gâché la
manifestation qu'on vous votre
rassemblement
oui ah ouais ça use voilà on aurait aimé
que ça se passe mieux qu'on puisse aller
de a à z
voilà avec réclamer ce qu'on demande en
fait
nos demandes a rejoint de aux
organisations syndicales de sortir du
ségur en fait parce qu'on sait que
ce qu'ils ont proposé aux aiguilleurs
c'est pas les revendications du
personnel hospitalier et l'hôpital va
mal et c'est pas le ségur qui va le
soigner en fait c'est à dire qu'est ce
que quelles retombées vous avez du ségur
pour le moment qui vous font penser
qu'il faut vraiment que les
organisations appart quitté négociations
mais en fait ils parlent ils ont parlé
un petit peu des salaires mais on voit
là on a bien compris que des salaires
il voulait peut-être d augmenter mais si
on travaillait plus
par contre pour l'ouverture des lits
pour voilà quoi sauver les lits
d'hospitalisation du service public
ils ont même pas parler quand on compte
donc deux coups de quoi vous souffrez
aujourd'hui vous dans votre travail mais
on souffre de ne pas pouvoir accueillir
les passions convenablement
on l'a vu pendant la période du coc vie
d'un ça soit pour nous pour les patients
on n'était pas protégée en fait quand on
est en france et on a manqué de moyens
est ce que vous pensez qu'aujourd'hui
puisque le ségur vous paraît décevant
par et adhésion aux soignants qu'on a
interrogés y compris vous si vous pensez
que la mobilisation des hospitaliers va
se poursuivre oui bah j'espère qu'elle
va se poursuivre en tout cas nous donne
au toit hôpital quelques l hôpital
hôpital beaujon en fait à clichy dans le
92 nous voilà quoi dans l'hôpital
beaujon va continuer à faire des
assemblées générales pour informer les
gens karba le ségur en fait c'est pas du
tout ce qu'on attendait en fait
la mobilisation est là depuis plus d'un
an même depuis plusieurs années voilà
ils ont en train de casser le service
public et nous l'hôpital public on y
tient coi
je vous remercie en faveur donc vous
voyez une fin de manifestation une
dispersion dans le calme à contrairement
à tout ce qui s'est passé toute la
journée une manifestation assez violente
avec des blessés peut-être des blessés
graves d'une consoeur de journalistes
mais maintenant évidemment l'ambiance
étonnamment était la liesse générale
après une journée très très tendue et
ici sur la playlist des invalides en
fait la nasse se referme autour du métro
et les manifestants au fil du temps sont
engagés à descendre dans la station pour
juste quitté les lieux
merci à vous quel type ethnique on va
écouter maintenant la maire de paris
anne hidalgo pour qu'il est
indispensable de recentrer l'économie
vers le milieu de la santé oms les coûts
il faut réorienter notre économie vers
la santé vers le soin on a bien vu qu'on
a besoin de tous ces métiers qui
évidemment ne peuvent pas être mis
exactement sur le terrain de métiers
dans lesquels il y a
là une compétition une compétitivité on
est dans les métiers du soin dans les
métiers de l'humain et il faut vraiment
que on réoriente y compris la dépense
publique vers ces métiers essentiels on
a bien vu qu'on ne peut pas se passer
d'un système qui soit solidaire
performant qui prennent en compte les
plus fragiles je pense à nos aînés je
pense aussi aux personnes sans domicile
fixe ou personne isolée action dndi
d'elle d'anne hidalgo la maire de paris
on retrouve rachid digoit infirmiers au
bloc opératoire du centre hospitalier
william morey président du collectif
interlock vous êtes toujours avec nous
merci d'ailleurs vous avez entendu à
l'instant anne hidalgo est ce que ces
propos font écho
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui à paris et
dans toute l'aviation
bien sûr ça fait coincer la ligne de
conduite contient depuis le début on
s'est demandé des moyens pour pour les
hôpitaux des moyens financiers des
moyens humains puisque la clé de coville
a révélé que on a manqué de bras on ya
salut réaménager des blocs opératoires
ont des animations donc manqué
d'animations à ce qui ce qui était quand
même très problématique pendant cette
crise en fait la surprise à l'arrivée
les vraiment au manque de moyens et
c'est vrai que madame hidalgo quand elle
parle de recentrer sur l'humain c'est
exactement ce qu'on demande aussi cccc
de l'huma remettre l'humain au coeur au
coeur des établissements de santé
vous restez avec nous on va vous montrer
des images ces images fortes de tension
aujourd'hui entre les forces de l'ordre
et les manifestants
regardez cette manifestante en blouse
que l'on voit ici
et bien c'est certainement une
professionnelle de la santé
la brutalement été percutée par une
charge des forces de l'ordre d'une
violente
illustration de ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui en marche donc de cette
manifestation des soignants qui a
dégénéré cet après midi comment vous
réagissez
lorsque vous voyez ce type d'image c'est
terrible je pense d'abord à ma collègue
après je pense que c'est parce qu'il
faut aller les violences et parce qu'il
faut retenir je pense qu'il ya eu une
très grosse mobilisation aujourd'hui que
ce soit du côté des soignants aider la
population on peut remercier une
nouvelle fois et je pense que c'est ce
qu'il faut retenir ce gros mouvements
ces hausses unité nationale qui s'est
faite autour des soignants pour mettre
des moyens dans l'hôpital public et plus
largement dans les établissements de
santé
quand on voit que les manifestations se
déroulent toujours avec beaucoup de
difficultés elles sont émaillés de
heurts cette manifestation deux de vos
confrères mais pas seulement on a vu les
des scènes de violence lors des
manifestations du gilet jaune tout
récemment je le disais tout à l'heure
lors d'une manifestation pour dénoncer
les violences policières présumées le
racisme au sein des forces de l'ordre
qu'est ce que vous vous dites on
entendait tout à l'heure l'un de nos
invités lui ont pointé la responsabilité
du didier lallement le le préfet de
police
écoutez il ya une responsabilité en tout
cas gouvernemental c'est c'est comme
dans notre secteur on n'est pas écoutés
on se sent méprisée
donc à un moment donné les gens les gens
sont en colère donc vu qu'il n'ya pas
possibilité d'avoir de discussion avec
avec toutes ces personnes haut placées
et basse et la coller c'est la violence
s'exprime malheureusement on en arrive à
des points des fois ils sont critiqués
cc c'est regrettable en tout cas qu'il
n'y ait pas un espace de discussion ou
une écoute de la part du gouvernement
casser c'est ce qu'on peut regretter
pour tout revoir ces violences la
préfecture de police qui a réagi sur
twitter on l'a dit cet après midi elle
appelle à nouveau au calme
voici son tweet des individus violents
n'ont pas leur place dans une
manifestation pacifique et
l'administration a également informé
qu'à à 17h24 interpellations ont donc
été enregistrés ces deux derniers bilans
à 17 heures on compte donc 24
interpellations a chip digoit vous êtes
toujours avec nous peut-être vous voulez
réagir sur ce twitt de la préfecture de
paris
en fait on peut être que d'accord avec
lui il faut il faut appeler au calme
il faut que les choses se temporise
après quand je faisais une grosse colère
nous on peut noter également de notre
côté une grosse colère de remercie les
établissements et les directions
notamment qui ont assigné le personnel à
100 % notamment dans certains blocs
opératoires comme au chu de dijon a pour
moteur enfin je pourrais vous en citer
énormément donc je vous parlais de
colère la colère elle exprime aussi de
ce côté-là part des directions qui prive
les personnels soignants de leur droit
de grève et ça aujourd'hui c'est
inadmissible donc on voudrait aussi le
christ sur vos plateaux 7 cette manière
de faire de nos établissements
mais où pour revenir à cette
manifestante tout à l'heure qui a été
renversée 1
entre les lords haute tension entre les
forces de l'ordre et les manifestants on
aurait pu éviter cela peut-être qu'en
pensez vous à écouter en tout cas
n'avait pas l'air très très menaçante ou
je ne sais pas et c'était page était pas
dans le contexte quel pc c'est difficile
pour moi d'interpréter sur des images
mais bon voilà a priori elle était
chargée malheureusement je pense je
pense plutôt à aider et à sa famille
dans un premier temps c'est vrai que la
situation aujourd'hui à déraper on peut
le regretter
ben on va quand même peut-être un mot
quand même sur ce qui s'est passé en
province parce que c'est vrai qu'à paris
à des manifestations qui ont dégénéré on
l'a suivi tout cet après midi mais en
prenant ça s'est bien passé je suis en
tout cas c'est très très pacifique en
aller retour des territoires qui sont
très positif c était il ya une grosse
mobilisation aussi dans les territoires
ce qu'il faut noter un très pacifiste
donc on est on est très satisfaits de
cette journée qui est qui est une
première parmi tant d'autres un
puisqu'il ya déjà d'autres dates qui
sont annoncées notamment celle du 30
juin et 7 peut-être du 14 juillet où on
va se focaliser sur celle là et
continuer la lutte malheureusement
envers ce gouvernement est inondé les
prises
on va trouver merci à vous rachid digoin
infirmiers bloc opératoire du centre
hospitalier william morey président du
collectif
un père bloc on va retrouver maintenant
on a des jardins razak poursuivre ce
moment de la dispersion du de cette
manifestation nadège où on est cette
situation
écoutez samantha ils sont plus que
quelques dizaines de manifestants sur
cette place des invalides ne sait par
les forces de l'ordre sur un petit
périmètre maintenant des manifestants et
bien qui je vais le finir la journée sur
une belle note vous les entendez vous
les voyez ils sont en train de danser de
chanter
donc voilà des manifestants qui veulent
bien finir alors que tout au long de
l'après-midi et bien la manifestation en
soutien aux personnels hospitaliers à a
dégénéré sur cette place de des
invalides elle a pris son départ du
ministère de la santé il avait pour
objectif ces manifestantes se rendre
devant l'assemblée nationale et ça n'a
pas été possible ils sont restés tout le
long de l'après-midi sur cette place des
invalides ou à des affrontements ont eu
lieu entre certains manifestants et des
forces de l'ordre et les forces de
l'ordre qu'il vous le voyait à ma droite
sont en train est bien de demander aux
homards derniers manifestants sur place
de quitter les lieux de prendre le métro
ils sont en train de resserrer cette
année cette menace donc
station qui se termine bien qui touche à
sa fin sur cette place des invalides
avec le métro dernière nous et on se
dirigeait la bouche de métro pour un
bien pour quitter les lieux ces
manifestations si l'adage abderrazak
qu'un moment de la dispersion qui se
déroule donc dans le calme on le voit
derrière vous on va écouter quelques
manifestants 11 invalides maintenant moi
je trouve inadmissible le fait qu'on
vienne pour voilà en fait un clamait nos
droits et nos du on se retrouve en fait
encercler comme de voleurs à se faire
gazer avoir les yeux qui pleurent le nez
qui pique avec des bombes lacrymogènes
verser le tout à fait et en soignant que
c'est très dangereux et moi je trouve ça
inadmissible et le fait que voilà nous
on met quand même santé en jeu pour
venir en aide à la population et qu'on
se retrouve en fait encercler comme des
voleurs je trouve ça inadmissible il
faudrait peut-être que le gouvernement
se réveille parce que c'est bien beau d
derrière un bureau est de donner des
conseils mais quand on est sur le
terrain même ce n'est pas la même foi
actuellement les eaux plutôt son manque
de matériel en manque d'effectif ça je
le dis haut et fort on te retrouve
maintenant avec des dents des services
avec votre passion pour en affirmer une
étonnante pour cette inadmissible
donc nous on est épuisé on n'est pas
écoutés on se sent délaissé il faudrait
que l'étape fait quelque chose sinon de
mal finir parce que vu qu on nous prend
comme d'edel encore battue continue
comme ça les gens vont se prendre
combler dès la con on est
systématiquement contre la violence mais
le pouvoir a décidé qu'il jouerait sur
la violence sur la violence sur la
violence pour dire regardez c'est infect
gens ces soignants à qui on disait bravo
bravo bravo
et bien aujourd'hui on va l'aider crac
et bientôt comme dédé dangereux
personnage
ce fameux peuple qui revendiquent avec
de l ardeur il ne fait pourquoi mais il
le fait parce qu'il n'en peut plus il
est submergé en l'autre lui donner une
dette auquel chaque augmenté de 40 % 1
on a fermé plus de 2300 société
nationale enfin tant qu'à augmenter en
fait le chômage de plus de 10 e de 2009
cistes de personnes là il va y avoir une
vague encore deux millions de personnes
tu vois arriver on va arriver où la
vallée jusqu'à où ça m'attriste
profondément
parce que depuis le début tout se passer
correctement c'était une manifestation
bon enfant on sait faire entendre et en
arriver à attaquer les forces de l'ordre
ne s'est pas sûr que nous ça nous serve
à quelque chose
nous les forces de l'ordre on les voit
quand on passe à côté alors on les salue
on a du respect pour eux voilà est allé
leur foncer dedans ou leur balancer des
trucs directement c'est inacceptable ça
fait quand même assez mal après ce qui
s'est passé en france avec d'épidémie
qu'ovide de voir que des le premier
rassemblement bon ben voilà c'est le
même traitement
inquiets qui est donnée donc un jour on
cogne sur les pompiers aujourd'hui c'est
des soignants c'est du grand n'importe
quoi
l'espoir c'est que les gens se rendent
compte petit à petit de la façon dont
est gouvernée
voilà je pense que ça devient criant bon
après on peut toujours garder les yeux
fermés
mais à partir mans les ouvre ça devient
assez évident quand même ne sommes pas
écoutés
nos revendications ne sont pas prises en
compte
voilà pensée réaction alors que cette
jolie mobilisation à paris elle touche à
sa fin mais au moment de la dispersion
arachidier goy vous êtes toujours avec
nous ainsi remis au bloc opératoire du
centre hospitalier william morey
président du collectif inter blog vous
nous disiez tout à l'heure qui aurait
une nouvelle journée de manifestation le
30 juin probablement le 14 juillet n'est
pas le seul à avoir annoncé ces deux
journées cet après midi sur notre
antenne est ce qu'il faut craindre de
nouveaux débordements
pour les prochaines journées de
mobilisation en tout cas on espère on
espère que l'on a vu malheureusement
tient un rapport de force qui s'est fait
dans la violence aujourd'hui
malheureusement pour le regretter en
tout cas la volonté de tous les
soignants et de ceux qui se mobilisent
et visage et ce n'est pas du tout la
violence un c est pacifique et de
revendiquer nos droits dans dans un
calme précis donc
donc personnellement je ne crains pas du
tout un regain de violence sur les
prochaines la mobilisation alors c'est
aujourd'hui d'actions nationales elles
répondaient à l'appel d'une dizaine de
syndicats de collectifs de deux
soignants est ce que vous appelez aussi
les français à venir manifester avec
vous le 30 juin prochain
peut-être le 14 juillet on a vu beaucoup
de gilet jaune aussi présents
aujourd'hui
bien sûr puisque c'est c'est un combat
qui les concerne aussi un on sait que
l'hôpital public si là il en charge de
du public ce fait est notamment dans les
adore dans le secteur du public à la
grosse partie sans distinction donc ce
qu'on valait concerne donc on les
appelle tout autant que les soignants à
venir réclamer des moyens pour l'hôpital
public on ça va coïncider à peu près
avec les réponses attendues dans le
cadre du ségur de la santé aussi ce sera
probablement sur ce mois de juillet
est ce que à ce niveau là justement vous
avez des espoirs de voir enfin le
système de santé français se relancer
alors quand ma main bien sûr il ya eu un
gros un boulet cette annonce de la part
du gouvernement
comment voulez vous que pendant quelques
semaines on ressent d'un système de
santé en entier sait c'est impossible
c'est surtout que le gouvernement n'a
annoncé clairement au niveau du ségur
aucun budget pour l'hôpital est ce que
vous avez entendu combien allait
investir le gouvernement dans l'hôpital
en a entendu pour le tourisme pour
l'aéronautique pour le zoo pis pour les
hôpitaux n'a entendu du toulon que on
peut que s'étonner de ces négociations
qui je pense la mèneront à rien puisque
une partie en tout cas des organisations
qu'on vous présente à naples étaient
conviés à ce c'est dur on s'explique
toujours pourquoi et et on leur pose la
question gouvernement aujourd'hui
pourquoi ils nous ont invités au
lancement puisque à priori on était
légitime pour y participer à ce
lancement est pas pour les suit un
chiffre ou en tête que vous pourriez
avoir pour relancer le système de sens
que tout à l'heure on n'en entendait ce
chiffre 15 milliards d'euros
moi je pense qu'on était je pense que là
tu étais plus sur les 30 milliards donc
après il faudrait bien plus que ça toute
façon ça fait ça fait des années qu'on a
pas réinvesti dans les hôpitaux donc
malheureusement on court après après un
chiffre qui se pensent dépasse dépasser
30 milliards d'euros c'est certain
surtout après la crise du coc vide on
sait que l'établissement a été très
affaiblie puisqu'ils n'ont pas eu
d'activité ils ont dû réinvestir dans
des dans des matériaux qui n'avaient pas
notamment dans des respirateurs dans du
matériel de protection
donc tout ça c'est un coup donc ça tout
ça va être ajoutées à la note des
établissements puisque c'est les
établissements qui vont en pâtir
aujourd'hui on se pose vraiment la
question de ce que le gouvernement
préconise pour pour les hôpitaux et les
établissements de santé en général
en ce moment on le rappelle jérôme
fallon le directeur général de la santé
il est entendu par la commission
d'enquêté parlementaire à la fin
et nationale ça se déroule en ce moment
à un moment où nous nous parlons
cette commission denquête ce ségur de la
santé ces manifestations dans la rue
c'est le même combat finalement c'est
pas dit assez tout cas tout est dit et
c'est clair mais je pense qu'il faut
prendre chaque problème par rapport à du
social renoncer c'est une affaire de
manquement par rapport à tout tous les
équipements de protection toute cette
gestion du comité donc cette cette
gestion a mis à une certaine colère et a
rajouté une colère au niveau des
soignants ça c'est certain
par rapport à tout ce qu'on a vécu par
rapport à l'afrique au vide 1 je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la une que vidal est
décriée notamment je vous parlais d'un
cas sur le chu de toulouse où ou la
direction s'octroie la prime de 1500
euros alors qu'elle va donner à son
personnel uniquement les 500 euros donc
si vous voulez c'est c'est tout ce
contexte là que aujourd'hui on bien on
vient revendiquer c'est plus possible de
continuer comme ça avec des directions
qui sont complètement déconnectés de la
réalité par la colère elle est certaine
les soignants en tout cas ce sont
arrêterons pas là
donc ce que vous dites c'est que s'il
faut réformer le système de santé il
faut commencer il faut évidemment de
l'argent c'est le nerf de la guerre mais
il faut aussi repenser une organisation
nouvelle et bien sûr et surtout fossé il
faut solliciter les agents du terrain
aujourd'hui quand on parle de la crise
du combi de ce ne sont pas les ars qui
nous ont qui nous ont dicté commencer un
ce sont les équipes qui sont organisés
en interne pour tout réorganiser le
système de prise en charge des patients
donc si vous voulez il ya une
déconnexion totale entre on va dire les
hautes sphères et le terrain donc si
monsieur vers en a parlé de retour
d'expérience au lancement du c'est dur
et bien qu'il appelle les gens du
terrain et qu'il leur fasse confiance
aussi et aujourd'hui on représente ces
personnes et du terrain donc vous
attendait des réponses concrètes pour
réconcilier les gens du terrain et les
hautes sphères comme vous dites si bien
sûr bien sûr on attend des réponses
concrètes et surtout on attend que en
le gouvernement sollicite les bonnes
personnes qui sont ces bonnes personnes
selon vous les acteurs du terrain c'est
ce que j'ai à vous dire les infirmiers
les aides soignants les médecins tous
les corps qui ont participé à la gestion
de la crise et qui connaissent
exactement l'ampleur de ce qu'il faut
réaliser en termes d'organisation pour
remettre sur pied à l'hôpital public qui
souffrent énormément
vous vous avez vous ressenti une
déconnexion
au plus fort de cette crise sanitaire
entre ces horaires que vous dénoncez et
les gens du terrain bien sûr mais aussi
par exemple on a eu des retours de
collègue anesthésiste qui sont partis à
la grèce notamment côté les plans blancs
ont été déclenchées peut penser arrivé
et que ça on allait leur sortir un plan
tous et pour l'organisation et en
faisant du tout à mettre en oeuvre
donc si vous voulez y avait rien de
préparé c'est si je vous disais c'est
les équipes qui sont mis à pied d'oeuvre
pour tout organiser donc c'est sûr
qu'elle déconnexion totale entre les
agents du terrain et les hautes sphères
ça c'est clair et net
l'avenir de du système de santé français
est ce que réellement vous êtes
optimiste à disons qu'on a quand même
une touche d'optimisme puisqu'on voit
les mobilisations aujourd'hui qui ont
été actives a été énorme donc on a
espoir on a espoir d'être entendu et
d'instaurer ce sera pour deux sens
puisque malheureusement il ya que ça qui
peut nous faire entendre aujourd'hui on
leur dette
le regard qu'on soit pas écouté conçoit
pas pris au sérieux et que les premiers
de cordée comme on nous appelle les
infirmiers les aides soignants soit pris
en compte par eux soient pris en compte
il n'y a pas que la parole des médecins
parlent de la part des médecins s'est
par rapport au collectif inter hôpitaux
qui était intronisé au c'est dur et pas
et pas les autres collectifs de
soignants par exemple pense aussi qu'il
peut aboutir en la vie sur des
manifestations qui dégénèrent ce qu'il
faut prendre ce risque
encore et encore disons que
est-ce que vous avez une solution vous
pour nous à part à part la rue puisque
les n'y a pas et il n'y a pas d' écoute
il n'y a pas de avec le gouvernement il
ya propose possibilité de se faire
entendre donc malheureusement on est
obligés de sortir dans la rue
merci à vous d'avoir répondu en direct
sur question je rappelle que vous êtes
donc infirmé au bloc opératoire du
centre hospitalier william morey
président du collectif inter bloc rachid
digoin merci à vous on va retrouver tout
de suite 4 ça pique nique pour faire le
point maintenant sur cette manifestation
qui arrive à son terme puisque on en est
au moment de la dispersion katia oui
alors en fait
en effet il ya eu la dispersion il suit
actuellement dans le métro car la nasse
amenait les manifestants qui restait
dans le métro d'envoyer une ambiance de
fête autour de moi ça continue
apple continue parce que vous savez que
cette manifestation était entachée par
deux de vraiment de violents
affrontements toute la journée beaucoup
de lacrymo et en ce moment lavez le
coude et festive a repris le dessus avec
des soignants toujours présent sur les
lieux
et là je suis avec annie chaque élève
infirmière et la part d'un élève en
médecine
étudiante en médecine et qui va nous
nous dire comment ça se passe pour le
moment qu'est ce que vous ressentez pour
les soignants et les étudiants
soigneusement bon bah c'est vrai qu'au
début on s'attendait pas à autant de
cerexhe on s'attendait à une
manifestation assez pacifique qui n'a
pas vraiment été le cas
[Musique]
et même par rapport aux règles du code
ville on a tous été vraiment mis
ensemble même là par exemple nous en
certes mais c'était quand même très
sympathique manifestation est bon ben
voilà j'espère qu'on a été un peu
écoutés dont vous n'avez pas été au
centre des affrontements en fait j'ai
été un moment mais j'ai eu un peu peur
parce que j'ai pas l'habitude
de tout ça moi j'ai fait que des
manifestations médical mais à bon bah
c'est pas grave c'est la vie aujourd'hui
quelles revendications vous en tant
qu'étudiante vous savez ce qu'ils vous
êtes en quelque sorte qu'elle veut voilà
de l'argent pour l'hopital s'il vous
plaît est ce que vous êtes très
mobilisés au sein d'autres professions
que ce soit des professions qui exercent
des jeunes les étudiants non mais je
pense qu on est super mobilisés après on
sait très bien qui a pas assez d'argent
et après on reste très solidaire mais ce
serait bien quand même qu'on nous écoute
et un petit pas ce qu'on a on vient
souvent de manifestations très pacifique
là c'est moi qui avais un peu de
violence la première fois que je vois ça
mais je pense je sais qu'ils en ont
marre
les gens en ont marre peut-être
comptez-vous ce n'était pas des gens
mais sinon je sais pas c'est vraiment
passé mais c'était très sympa quand même
car nous avons été très étonnés par la
violence policière que même avec mes
scandale je pensais pas que ça irait
mais effectivement ça arrive et c'est
dommage ça a été un peu mélangé mais ces
deux matches
je remercie
aïcha l'envol à une fin de manifestation
assez incongru 1 comme vous voyez avec
tout à coup une fête qui s'est improvisé
ici dans le métro avec beaucoup de bonne
humeur et le pacifiste qui a manqué
évidemment à cette manifestation qui a
été marquée par de très nombreuses
violences avec des blessures des des
jets de lacrymogènes et jets de grenades
de tous types et des jets de projectiles
voilà mais en tout cas
actuellement il reste très peu de
manifestants sur la place des invalides
y sont regroupées de manière très serrée
au niveau de la bouche de métro
ce qu'il reste peut-être ne sais pas
trop manifestants en eau et donc la
manifestation se poursuit ici on fait
avec et ça fait du bien qui est très
technique de voir aussi que de montrer
ces images de des images où tout se
déroule bien les manifestants sont
heureux content d'avoir manifesté pour
faire entendre leurs voix leurs
revendications même si c'est vrai il ya
eu on le rappelle quand même et c'est
important détention cet après midi qui
ont un petit peu assombri cette journée
d'action nationale on va revenir
justement sur ces tensions qui ont
émaillé la manifestation des soignants à
à paris
regardez
[Applaudissements]
pas contre
pourquoi
à
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
mon temps
c
on va retrouver rachid des gayettes
infirmiers au bloc opératoire du centre
hospitalier william morey président du
collectif inter blog vous êtes donc
toujours avec nous merci de nous
accompagner pour commenter donc cet
après midi de manifestations vous nous
annonciez tout à l'heure de nouvelles
manifestations le 30 juin le 14 juillet
peut-être est-ce qu'il faudra
s'organiser au niveau des personnels
soignants cette fois pour éviter des
débordements même si on sait il y aura
encore des forces de l'ordre qui seront
mobilisés pour encadrer ces
rassemblements parce que je pense que il
y avait déjà une organisation n'a -
puisque les services d'ordre de tous les
organes des sources syndicales étaient
présents donc je pense que de ce côté là
tout le monde était réglo après
peut-être revoir je sais pas au niveau
des cortèges à savoir peut-être
différencier je ne sais pas les usagers
des soignants malheureusement au
jourdain dans les images que je vois
aujourd'hui c'est pas beaucoup
j'ai pas beaucoup vu deux pouces
blanches dans dans l'erreur donc est-ce
que c'est uniquement la population
est-ce que c'est uniquement les
soignants je ne sais pas je peux pas
vous dire comme ça je participe à la
fois une particule et je ne participais
pas la manifestation
vous n'avez pas participé à la
manifestation on le rappelle il ya eu
oui à paris a eu donc des échauffourées
qui ont éclaté en marge de cette
manifestation des soignants avec des
jets de pro d2 projectiles et les forces
de l'ordre ont répliqué à coups de gaz
lacrymogènes on compte 24
interpellations selon un dernier bilan
de la préfecture de police et de
nombreux blessés
également peut-être aussi des de
nombreux manifestants qui ont été
blessés tout à l'heure on a montré et
vous les avez commenter avec nous ces
images d'une dune confrères qui
était prise à parti pris on va dire
entre les forces de l'ordre et les
manifestants
mais c'est vrai que c'est malheureux de
voir une collègue se faire charger de la
sorte
malheureusement la violence était au
rendez vous aujourd'hui de part et
d'autre donc a priori que faire pour les
prochaines c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué pour nous c'est toujours
compliqué on sait que et un mouvement
social d'une contestation donc ça peut
faire partie malheureusement des
débordements alors un mot peut-être sur
l'état d'esprit des personnels soignants
dans ces personnels soignants il ya des
médecins il ya des infirmiers il ya des
brancardiers je les aide soignant des
gens cons qui sont donc on a beaucoup vu
à pied d'oeuvre durant cette crise
sanitaire au plus fort de cette crise
qu'est-ce qui domine aujourd'hui je
parlais de cet état d'esprit est ce qu
il ya de la colère mais ça va ou même au
delà de la colère est ce que vous vous
ressentez qu'il peut y avoir une forme
de radicalisation aussi des personnels
soignants
enfin une colère qui se radicalise plus
tôt je ne parlerai pas de radicalisation
c'est pas du tout notre leitmotiv en
tout cas nous les soignants c'est pas
beau valeur aujourd'hui il ya une colère
il ya aussi une fatigue psychologique
c'était très intense tout ce qu'on a
vécu donc par la suite je pense qu'il y
aura des traumatismes par rapport à
toutes ces prises en charge pour qu'on a
pu avoir qu'on a pu faire ça ce sera
dans le temps qu'on va le revoir enfin
qu'on voit qu'on va le reconnaître
donc malheureusement est ce qu'on va
perdre des collègues après tout cette
crise est ce qu'il y aura un après pour
l'hôpital parce que quand vous avez vu
le manque de moyens n'est pas très
attrayant pour les jeunes avec qui
voudraient s'orienter dans la voie du
milieu de la santé
donc aujourd'hui ça c'est encore tout
frais mais je pense que on va en faire
les frais dans non je pense dans six
mois un an
mieux le dialogue il est toujours à
l'ordre du jour quand je parlais de
durcissement justement de cet état
d'esprit des personnels soignants c'est
peut-être aussi un le ras-le-bol qui
domine parce que ces revendications on
les entend depuis des années ah ben
c'est pas foot c'est pas faute de les
répéter à nos revendications à ccc
toujours les mêmes en tout cas il ya un
socle commun de l'apport de tous les
soignants après chaque fois chaque
organisation a ses spécificités interne
pour les deux opérateurs mais en tout
cas il ya un socle commun qui est très
claire et est malheureusement comme je
disais tout à l'heure on n'a pas d'
écoute de la part du gouvernement donc
c'est sûr que l'on ne sait plus comment
réagir face à ces ça c'est certain
on va retrouver dit la femme vous où
vous restez avec nous c'est possible de
votre côté on va retrouver lille afin
lit la femme ouzou donc lhi la fao en
est là
la fin de cette manifestation ce que le
calme visiblement est revenu vous nous
confirmez ou effectivement samantha le
calme est revenu même si les forces de
l'ordre continuent d'empêcher en fait
les manifestants de se sortir de la
place des invalides en fait ils veulent
absolument obligé de tout le monde à
prendre le métro il y à peu près une
petite centaine de personnes encore qui
se trouve là tout se passe dans une
bonne ambiance et on entend de la
musique les jeunes chantent ici mais
c'est vrai que cette fin qui est assez
joyeuse finalement tranche
particulièrement avec les moments
d'extrême violence auquel on a assisté
il ya quelques heures pendant cette
manifestation qui avait très bien
commencé et qu'il faut le rappeler était
la première manifestation déclaré
accepter par la préfecture depuis la fin
du confinement
donc oui bonne ambiance au début au
milieu ça a été absolument
catastrophique très violent on a
vraiment a vu plusieurs les
interpellations plusieurs arrestations
on a vu des personnes blessées dont une
journaliste qui était gravement blessé
au niveau de la jambe et donc c'est des
tensions qui ont été provoquées par des
petits groupes des groupes d'hommes
habillés en noir qui étaient cagoulés et
qui finalement lancé des projectiles sur
les forces de l'ordre qui au début était
statique et qui au bout d'un moment on
finit pas riposté à coups de gaz
lacrymogènes donc solaire était
irrespirable pendant plusieurs heures
sur cette place des invalides on a vu du
mobilier urbain qui a été détruit et ça
tout ça finalement ça a été me regretté
un par les soignants et les participants
que ce soit les soignants les syndicats
comme de nombreux gilet jaune qui
étaient là aujourd'hui et qui on
trouvait dommage que finalement ces
violences viennent entacher le message
de départ le message qu'il voulait faire
ressortir en se mobilisant aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup les la fameuse ou pour
toutes ces précisions vous revenez vers
nous si vous avez
de nouvelles informations en tout cas on
voit que derrière la situation elle
semble stable derrière vous le retour au
calme donc à paris du côté des invalides
rachid digoit vous êtes toujours avec
nous rappelle vous êtes infirmier au
bloc opératoire du centre hospitalier
william morey président du collectif
inter-blogues au delà des revendications
de cette journée spéciale pour les
personnels soignants
ce qu'on constate avec ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui cet après midi à paris
c'est qu'on ne peut plus manifester je
veux dire sans violences dans la
capitale particulièrement bas c'est sûr
que c'est ça a l'air très compliquées
entre pia c'est parce que c'est parce
qu'on ressent du côté des deux côtés de
la province alors qu'il faudrait
délocaliser les manifestations en
province
blague à part mais oui c'est sûr que il
ya une colère sociale qui est très
importante
il n'y a pas plus secteur de la santé
qui a impacté il ya beaucoup d'autres
secteurs
donc malheureusement ça s'exprime comme
cela aussi on peut regretter l'absence
de part et d'autre il faut il faut des
condamnés pour pas on va voir ce genre
de situation ça ces manifestations aussi
qu'il s'est déroulée
alors qu'on est en face de déconfinement
plutôt avancé mais il ya quand même un
risque quand même
lakovic 19 n'a pas disparu en france
tout à fait là pas disparu d'ailleurs il
ya même des clusters qui sont un peu
réapparu à l'étranger aussi notamment
donc il faut rester très prudent je vois
que les maisons barrière où était quand
même respecter avec le port du masque et
là ya pas eu forcément peut-être la
distanciation auquel cas le port du
masque
je pense l'hygiène des mains a été
respectée en tout cas d'un autre cadre
en province a été très très respectée
donc oui c'est sûr qu'on en perde de
déconfinement il faut il faut rester
vigilant je pensais que l année reste la
véracité de ce virus n'est plus à
prouver aujourd'hui et on ne connaît pas
assez encore pour dire que tout est fini
alors en juillet donc ce sera encore un
mois qui va être chargé
tant sur le plan des revendications des
personnels soignants mais mais ça ira
peut-être au-delà cette vague de grogne
sociale
ce défi aussi de la relance et
économique en france
elle complique la tâche des autorités
dans ce contexte là finalement est-ce
qu'il faut pas faire preuve de patience
et de retenue
peut-être je pense que mon à exprimer
notre colère depuis bien trop longtemps
on l'a on va essayer d'oublier
maintenant c'est fini on dit beaucoup de
choses donc aujourd'hui il faut nous
laisser la place il faut il faut nous
nous accueillir dans les négociations
temporiser ce serait laisser le temps au
gouvernement malheureusement alors qu'
il ya beaucoup de solutions à l'est on
sait aujourd'hui qu'il existe beaucoup
de finances dans certains domaines donc
il faudrait peut-être revoir une
redistribution enfin il ya beaucoup de
solutions à en tout cas à étayer
on va terminer avec vous sur les
principales revendications qu'il faut
retenir de cette journée de
manifestation ça concerne l'augmentation
des salaires plus de moyens en termes de
ressources humaines mais aussi l'arrêt
de la suppression des délits notamment
vous pouvez vous nous résumer le corps
de revendications c'est exactement ça
c'est des moyens humains financiers
l'arrêt des fermetures de lits l'arrêt
des structures d'établissements
notamment remettre le patient au coeur
du système de soins et que
l'organisation soit aussi la tripartite
avec les soignants et médecins et la
direction
et pour conclure vous pensez qu'on va
tirer les leçons
de cette crise sanitaire de lakovic 19
en tout cas du côté des soignants il ya
un retour d'expérience donc on va tirer
beaucoup de leçons de tout ce qui s'est
passé
malheureusement je ne serais pas aussi
affirmatif du côté du gouvernement
notamment avec des comportements des
directions qui repartent dans la hausse
à d'anciens temps acquis qui abusent de
leur pouvoir malheureusement donc de ce
côté là on peut quand même être plutôt
pessimiste merci à vous rachid de digoin
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes ainsi remis au
bloc opératoire du centre hospitalier
william morey président du collectif
inter bloc merci à vous on va rejoindre
tout de suite les la fable ou qui suit
donc la fin de cette manifestation on en
est à la dispersion et ça se passe
plutôt bien
c'est tant mieux les la fin oui
effectivement samantha parce que comme
je vous le disais on a eu des moments
vraiment très on a vu des moments très
violent ici sur cette place des
invalides on a vu plusieurs personnes
blessées on a vu plusieurs
interpellations aussi et puis des
échanges très nourris et très dur entre
les forces de l'ordre et des groupes
d'hommes masqués et habillés de noir qui
ont provoqué les forces de l'anp pour
nom à plusieurs reprises avant que les
forces de l'ordre ne finisse par
riposter alors effectivement là
maintenant comme vous voyez peut-être
derrière moi sur les images de dounia
syrie il ya encore les forces de l'ordre
qui sont là et qui veulent absolument
obliger les manifestants qu'il reste
encore ici à prendre le métro et a
quitté les lieux ça fait presque deux
heures qu'ils demandent aux manifestants
de quitter les lieux
et donc là il ya encore quelques une
petite centaine de personnes derrière
nous qui sont là et qui j'ai
l'impression envie que les choses
continuent parce que c'est vrai que
effectivement l'ambiance est devenue
beaucoup plus calme plus festive que ce
qu'on a vu un peu plus tôt dans la
journée mais pour l'instant oui la
dispersion se passe plutôt dans le calme
pour l'instant pas de tension notable à
signaler à cette heure ci merci beaucoup
il la femme et pour tout
les précisions trois mois après le début
de la crise sanitaire les soignants sont
descendus dans la rue aujourd'hui
partout en france dans les grandes
villes de l'hexagone et à paris
également pour réclamer plus de moyens
pour l'hôpital à paris où il ya eu donc
des échauffourées qui ont éclaté en
marge de la manifestation à des
soignants avec des jets de projectiles
auxquelles les forces de l'ordre ont
répondu par des tirs de gaz lacrymogène
le bilan à 17 heures le bilan de la
préfecture de police de paris 24
interpellations
on va revenir en images sur les temps
forts de cette journée à paris avec fait
attention
regardez
[Applaudissements]
pas contre
à
[Applaudissements]
franchement les gars c'est pas
voilà pour ces images de tension c'était
à paris cet après midi du côté des
invalides lors du rassemblement des
personnels soignants dans le cadre d'une
grande journée d'action nationale on a
manifesté également en province là bas
tout s'est bien passé dans le calme
le calme est est de retour à paris
également on l'a noté tout à l'heure
avec une reporter pour la dispersion à
19h vous retrouverez interdit
d'interdire avec frédéric taddeï et puis
à 20 heures l'info avec stéphanie de
murs eux ce sera l'occasion de revenir
sur cette journée d'action nationale des
personnels soignants et ces tensions à
paris merci à de votre attention
excellente soirée à vous sur arte
à
[Musique]